[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale avec
stéphane laborde bonjour stéphane
bonjour et loi uigea là qui s'annonce
palpitante tout à fait finale
gigantesque garry kasparov contre l'ivg
inhibe arai f garry kasparov on le
connaît il est champion du monde higuain
di maria il est également très très fort
puisqu'il fait partie des dix meilleurs
joueurs mondiaux depuis très très
longtemps fait plus de dix ans depuis
les années 90 à peu près on a vu
notamment de sa défense favorite sur e4
c'est aussi ce donc on aura peut-être
droit à une française aujourd'hui si le
sport joue en 4 sans aucun doute une
défense française alors que là nous
allons bientôt assister à la cérémonie
donc de d'ouverture de cette finale qui
sera suivie par la série clôture vous
voyez il ya beaucoup de journalistes sur
scène il ya donc les arbitres il y à
jean-claude loubatière & carry kasparov
et d'evgeni berdyev qui doivent être en
backstage et donc on voit beaucoup
beaucoup de journalistes sur la scène à
noter qu'hier a eu lieu la remise des
philidor ce n'est les récompenses qui
pour les révélations de l'année et c'est
christian bauer qui a remporté le
trophée
effective horreurs qui fectivement a
fait une belle saison puisqu'il se
retrouve deuxième français ex-aequo avec
etienne bacrot on ne l'attendait pas là
c'est sûr c'est sûr christian bauer est
extrêmement fort mais ici à la coupe du
monde et bien il n'a pas à prouver sa
valeur puisqu'il était un petit peu hors
course n'a jamais vraiment été présent
en tout cas là c'est la grande finale
donc le titre de champion du monde deux
parties rapides et en jeu stéphane mais
oui alors évidemment kasparov et quand
même gros favoris
kasparov qui va débuter avec les pièces
noir noir j'espère qu'elle est noire
dans la première partie donc encore un
avantage encore un avantage
effectivement pour youri kasparov alors
que là et bien
joueurs vont se mettre en place aulas et
ses complexes il ya toujours débuter ses
matches de qualification par les noirs
kasparov oui tout à fait c'est sans
doute parce qu'il a gagné sa poule je
crois que le règlement vous ça quand on
a gagné la poule eh bien nous avons les
noirs dans tous les matchs après ouais
mais le vainqueur de l'autre poule qui
aurait été adams aurait eu les noirs ça
c'est pas bien ça c'est pas sûr c'est
peut-être un tirage au sort pour la
finale oui tout à fait c'est possible et
peut-être il était hors jeu sort
systématique qui ai donné les noirs à
kasparov
coût de possibilités alors que sur scène
nous voyons larbitre éric murray qui
vient de passer qui est donc le gérons
des échiquiers électronique qui est
également larbitre l'homme orchestre de
cette organisation à noter qu'on a des
problèmes avec les chics electronics est
pas tout à fait au point une technique
utilisée la fédération pas au point pour
les parties semi-rapides non pas au
point que pour les parties semi-rapides
ça marche très bien pour les parties
langue mais pour les parties
semi-rapides surtout pour les blitz on a
vu que ça bloqué quasiment système a
systématiquement malheureusement
effectivement alors que nous attendons
donc que tout le monde soit en place
pour que l'organisation se passe bien et
sans douleur donc il va y avoir donc
jean-claude loubatière monsieur donc aux
ex bernard oheix qui est le président de
la cmec ou alors le directeur la sémec
étant l'organisation de l'événementiel à
cannes au palais des festivals
oui
alors que pour l'instant on a vu
apparaître jean-paul nous bâtir en fond
de scène mais pour l'instant se décide
pas à venir au centre de la scène pour
alors que nous présenter cette finale
nous avons notre cadreur qui essaie de
se frayer un espace parmi les
journalistes
enfin ça va pas être facile on sent que
dès que les joueurs vont arriver que ça
va être la frénésie du début de partie
eh bien ça ne sera pas bon ça y est ils
arrivent on va leur laisser la parole à
bernard oheix et jean-claude loubatière
pour tout le festival pour toute
l'équipe pour les joueurs pour le monde
des échecs mais avant mais avant un
partenaire officiel the bank un
partenaire qui offrent des cadeaux et
donc on appelle the bank pour bella
dernière distribution de cadeaux olivier
bernès directeur commercial the bank
qui va vous donc procédé au tirage bien
bonjour à tous bienvenue à la finale
donc on va comme tous les jours
maintenant faire le tirage aurait
demandé à bernard encore une fois d'être
la main innocente
aujourd'hui il ya double tirage puisque
c'est un final on a fêté ça donc les
deux premiers bulletins gagnants gagne
2000 francs et les deux bulletins
suivant gagne un pagne pilotes
alors il s'agit de madame ou
mademoiselle carla ricard
monsieur clandé jégou
donc ça c'était pour les 2000 francs
maintenant les deux pilotes
alors brigitte ges qui gagne un pilote
et nordine keira voilà félicitations aux
gagnants et bonne finale merci
bien
mais voilà donc
merci à deux banques merci à ce
partenaire officiel de la fédération
française des échecs jean-claude houba
tiers on voulait une coupe du monde dont
l'avait rêvé ça fait longtemps qu'on est
dessus et aujourd'hui et bien c'est le
moment de la finale avec je crois de
joueurs d'exception oui donc ce sens et
une finale de très grand niveau
puisqu'elle va opposer le numéro 10
mondial au numéro un mondial donc
c'était un match de très très haut
niveau
avec les blancs un joueur qui a
démarré le tournoi re
difficilement puisqu'il a perdu il faut
dire que c'était justement comme garry
kasparov
puis qui est à monter en puissance il a
gagné sa qualification de justesse à la
septième ronde en battant à régler noir
joël lautier
puis en quarts de finale il a éliminé
etienne bacrot et hier en demi-finale
contre judit polgar il a été
particulièrement impressionnant alors ce
joueur c'est le numéro 10 mondial c'est
un joueur qui a été
le second dans 2 gla d'ymir cram nique
pour ce match avec kasparov et puis
c'est un joueur aussi qui viennent de
disputer en septembre dernier à shenyang
la finale de la coupe du monde
cette fois ci pas d'échec rapide mais à
cadence normale et il avait donc perdu
cette finale contre analyse ce joueur
que vous aller applaudir c'est f gainey
bas relief
bravo en l'innovation est vite gaylib
arief
face à lui un joueur qui
est le numéro mondial depuis 15 ans et
qui
lorsque ce jeune et fougueux joueur
était arrivé sur l'échiquier
international il avait révolutionné
le milieu des échecs et conquis les
foules grâce à un style de jeu
extraordinaire éblouissant et puis le
temps a passé le style y rester mais
dans l'accord l'inconscient collectif il
est toujours il a un petit peu ici un
stoppée hier soir dans son match de
blida contre gries tchouk garry kasparov
a rappelé qu'il était toujours le jeune
joueur de 22 ans qui l'ogre de bakou
c'était toujours le même il est là c'est
garry kasparov
[Applaudissements]
et voilà nous voilà de retour
nous voilà de retour ici dans la cabine
de commentaires pour cette grande finale
entre gary kasparov et yevgeny variées
vous voyez qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
journalistes autour la table de jeu
beaucoup de photos sont prises des
joueurs faut espérer que ça va t'on pas
trop les déranger les flashs
et cette finale
qui s'annonce palpitante dont gary
kasparov et guérini bas relief ne va pas
tarder à commencer
larbitre va appuyer sur la pendule il
fait d'abord quitter les journalistes de
la scène
voilà les journalistes s'en vont
une fois qu'ils ont quitté la scène les
arbitres pour appuyer sur la pendule
une finale qui s'annonce palpitante
bas relief qui a été remarquable lors
des qualifications
il a éliminé judit polgar en demi-finale
par un jeu très précis
est il capable de tenir tête à kasparov
kasparov qui a été mis en difficulté par
great ue que lors de sa demi-finale où
il était obligé de concéder deux parties
nulles est obligé de terminer si on peut
dire le russe
par
alors que kiev guinea variés commence
par le coup cavaliers en f3
voilà cavaliers en f3 a été jouée par
barrière
ce couac à ce parent a répondu par
cavalier 6
les barrières a répliqué par c4
c5 a été jouée qu'à laisser trois des
cinq
donc c'est une anglaise
alors que beaucoup de coups ont été
joués
s'éprend des cinq cavaliers prendre des
cavalier prend ces trois noms si calais
prince et 3b pensée
3g si ça a été jouée
suivi par
sully par food et cinq échecs
food esat cinq échecs fou 17 et le cou à
2 à 4 et le coup à 4 voilà alors qu'ils
ont à nous rejoindre pour les
commentaires tout à fait donc voilà le
coup à 4 comme vous le voyez ici
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire dans cette
position pour probablement petit
avantage pour parler dief quand même
bizarre il a une majorité de pions au
centre d'afellay en a trois alors que
kasparov n'y en a que deux ici il ya
petit rock à venir est sans doute le
coût des deux des quatre pour prendre le
centre consolider la position au centre
et voilà les idées alors que ça je
voyais du fou g7
et petit rock
foo g7 petit rock garry kasparov art ok
et la barrière devrait sans doute joué
le coup d2 d4 c'est le coût attendu il
faut améliorer pour s'installer au
centre est contré le fou g7 tout à fait
se fout j'essaie de garry kasparov il
faut le bloquer il peut également jouer
le coup sûr la case le fou sur la case à
3 il sera pas forcément mauvais choix
c'est probablement la meilleure case de
développement pour ce fou alors que
l'ordinateur ici recommande le coût des
deux des quatre où x 3 d'ailleurs ça
tombe bien on est en harmonie avec
l'ordinateur alors que là stéphane au
niveau de l'ouverture est ce qu'on peut
faire un bilan est ce que kasparov a
plus ou moins réussi à surprendre
barrière ou bien est ce le contraire
mais pour l'instant je pense que les
deux joueurs sur un terrain connu
ce qu'ils ont joué assez vite il assez
bas relief qui réfléchit donc c'est
plutôt lui qui est mis en difficulté
pour l'instant dans cette ouverture
oui enfin ils seront avec qualité de
temps stéphanie l'on réfléchisse 23
minutes 30 enfin ils ont ils auraient dû
23 minutes 30 qui se réfléchit une
minute et demie chacun pour l'instant il
n'y a pas un gros écart à la pendule
mais c'est bas relief qui est en train
de réfléchir à noter que marc aillet fac
et blanc est quand même très fort et il
peut faire douter garry kasparov
puisqu'il a un énorme avantage face aux
joueurs c'est que son apporteur
d'ouverture c'est le coup un des quatre
ou un c4 et que ça c'est bien parce que
ça évite la rage dorff s'invite un âge
d'or fait c'est dans le style de kravica
utilisé pour battre kasparov lors de son
match à l'ombre
ou à troyes des jouets fou à 3
x 3 fait pression sur le pion c5
menace france et celles qui gagnent un
pion tout à fait et sur le p6 aucun
doute barrier jorat d2 d4 c'est ça son
idée alors on nous fait remarquer sur le
chat que la structure de pions va être
très très complexe ça va être un
imbroglio compliqué avec des pions dans
tous les sens c'est effectivement vrai
puisque ce n'est pas du tout une
structure de pions classique
alors que la maintenance et kasparov qui
entame sa réflexion
voyez d'un petit peu mieux les gagner
bas relief légèrement mieux mais on sait
que kasparov évidemment entre être mieux
voire même être gagnant et le battre il
ya un écart colossal stéphane
effectivement il ya des gars pour le
salon a vu
on a vu que il y en a pas il n'y a pas
vraiment de capri davantage peut-être
judit polgar d'un une qualification qui
avait pris un petit avantage mais ça n'a
pas suffi elle s'est ensuite fourvoyé
ducale a part of a réussi à gagner la
partie
exactement garry kasparov il est très
très fort en contre c'est un joueur très
résistant il se bat tout le temps il a
toujours dit trouve des idées les trouve
des chances c'est un excellent joueur
mais il finit par ayasse lui on l'a vu
hier quand tu dit paul gars qui est
comme la reine de larnack et bien
yvelines bas relief et garder son sang
froid a fait monter la pression et a
gagné une très belle partie il est donc
capable de mener à une partie du début à
la fin sans faire de fautes sans lâcher
la pression il y avait ni bas relief et
c'est ça qui fait peur à garry kasparov
qui est en train de réfléchir ici il ne
lui reste que 21 minutes 22 minutes
alors qu'on peut peut-être regarder un
plan sur la tête de gary kasparov un
grand plan
effectivement je vois là garry kasparov
oula leur avis il est peut-être dans les
bras il est vraiment être dans les mains
il était dans les mains alors kasparov
pas se contenter de la nulle dans cette
partie pour ensuite essayer de prendre
l'aventage avec les blancs c'est sans
doute ce qui va faire puisque ça lui
avait réussi contre vladislav tkachiev
est contre eux
at your ride choc tout à fait quand on
sait tous qu'il n'avait pas réussi avec
les blancs a
alors que sur le chat on nous propose le
coup à 7 assists stefan
wess est envisageable effectivement à 6
pour poser la question au fond est ce
qui s'échange contre le food et cet os
qui recule on est tout à fait alors je
pense que sur a6 et bien c'est un choix
que devra faire varier a priori le four
reviendra sur la case au 2 mai à 6 est
un bon coup puisque ça pose la question
aux fous donc ça c'est une bonne
remarque
alors que la casse période prend
beaucoup de temps
il en est à cinq minutes de réflexion
contre 2 sommes plus simplement à bas
relief et ses bas relief qui prend
l'avantagé à la pendule s'est barré free
prend l'avantagé rappelons que s'est
départi de 25 minutes par joueur et que
donc un avantage de trois minutes en
début et bien c'est un bel avantage
alors que là on dirait que kasparov fait
comme s'il avait déjà joué son coup
et pourtant on le voit pas
non non il en réflexion kasparov il est
en pleine réflexion garry kasparov il
est détaché des chicanes a pour une fois
il n'est pas goûté sur l'échiquier
pencher en mettant la pression physique
sur le son adversaire le menaçant d'un
coup de tête c'est vrai c'est bas relief
qui s'avance ses bas reliefs qui
s'avance vers garry kasparov et oui
alors que la position pour l'instant est
celle que vous voyez à l'écran que le
reste est variable et qui réfléchit pour
jouer est-ce que l'échiquier
électronique ne serait pas bloqué et
bien non je ne pense pas stéphane
puisque le bouton de la pendule de
kasparov et bien est remonté vers lui
donc c'est bien kasparov qui réfléchit
le coup proposer ces assisses bon alors
y en a d'autres par exemple qufu prend
fou ne serait pas forcément un bon choix
à stéphane non ça ramènerait une cure
vers le centre le pion à qui est sa
mènerait vers le centre qui serait
avancée et qui seraient de nouveau en
relation avec le reste des pions
puisqu'il pourrait être soutenu par le
coup c3 c4 pas forcément tout de suite
mais plus tard et donc sa re compacteurs
est entre guillemets la structure de
pions des blancs donc vous prend vous ce
n'est pas un très bon choix de garry
kasparov à moins qu'il y ait derrière
des complications qui nous échappe mais
en tout cas le coût attendu c'est le cou
à cette a6 puisque sur fou prend 17 eh
bien il ya cavaliers reprend défendant
l'option c5 voilà toute l'idée de ce
coût à 6
donc on attend que kasparov le jour où
il va peut-être jouer b6 mais je ne
crois pas il peut aussi jouer d'hab
c'est cette eau nautique sur a6 sur four
en fout évidemment il faut reprendre du
cavalier pour protéger le plan c 5
le chat nous demandent où est passé
robert et bien la réponse est simple il
est dans la salle en train de profiter
du spectacle
exceptionnellement robert s'est mis dans
le public et non pas aux commentaires
pourquoi pas après tout stéphane ça fait
peut-être un peu du bien de changer de
maître avec joël l'outil qui nous a
rejoint tout à l'heure non je pense
qu'il est avec une jeune fille en forme
baguette avec une banshee oui tout à
fait il ne nous quitterait pas pour
aller voir jouer de lautier mais pour
des raisons différentes
qui nous échappe
enfin bon tout ça ne nous regarde pas
alors que cast of commence à être mal
autant stéphane il n'a plus que 18
minutes 30 et bas reliefs à 23 30 ce qui
veut dire que question prend cinq
minutes de retard est-ce que bara y est
tu peux faire l'exploit ici stéphane ben
si ça continue oui si la continua acide
et s'il arrive à mettre la pression
autant à kasparov maintenant on sait que
kasparov quand y réfléchit c'est pas
pour rien en général il suit par une
rafale de coups oui il sent que c'est le
moment critique et il veut bien calculé
son coup garry kasparov il veut être sûr
de ce qu'il fait
n'hésitant plusieurs coups à six dames
c'est cette peut-être voilà c'est les
deux coups le ku'damm c7 qui des
champions le a6 qui attaquent le fou b5
peut-être dame b6 d'imbéciles
s'appréciant sur le fond des saints qui
plus tendancieuses stéphane puisqu'il y
à tour b1 qui se mettrait dans le champ
de la dame effectivement donc plus total
ces scènes plutôt à 6 ou alors peut-être
le coup mais cette b 6 en tout cas on ne
comprend pas vraiment quel est le gros
problème positionnelle que garry
kasparov se pose à mon avis il doit se
demander fermement s'il prend en b 5 ou
pas puisque c'est ça le changement
radical qui pourrait être réalisé tout
de suite garry kasparov à mon avis
réfléchit à en fou et non qu'ils
jouent le coup bessette b6 un petit coup
pas très et pas très efficace on
n'attend pas ce genre de coup la part de
castor faire la queue barrier fra quick
tempo au bar des 2 d-4d deux des quatre
îles se pose pas de questions bas relief
il lui met la pression à la pendule
il lui met une grosse pression il a six
minutes d'avancé menace pions prince et
5 et surtout princes et rois ont joué
tour c1
ces six avec un pion passer
des 4 il prend le sens défini barria
fils menace effectivement de prendre ces
5 avec une grosse activité de pièces ils
menacent peut-être dames deux tours
c'est un et tour f en d1
j'espère va jouer je crois qu'il a pris
en d4 il a joué à six maintenant et
jouer à 6 pose la question on fout ça y
est alors est-ce que le fou alors le
problème c'est que ça affaiblit le cube
et si ce goût c'est très curieuse que
fait kasparov à 6 c b6 on ne comprend
pas sûr fou prend 17 et bien que va-t-il
se passer je ne sais pas fort pointe du
kava livre probablement frais sans le
land allemand du team vds et protéger le
pion des six qu'elle est bien des
lécheurs star of pourquoi est-ce qu'il a
retardé le coups à si stéphane pourquoi
ne l'at il pas fait au coude avant c'est
toute la question on peut se poser
peut-être il veut pro il veut se
permettre de reprendre avec la dame en
17 mois il c'est possible mais sur dawn
princess est il y a quand même pu
compenser 5 quitte à ces problématiques
et non puisque cela mènerait à une
partie nulle voilà c'est ça l'idée alors
sans doute stephen sur foot rend fou
guernica sport veut reprendre de la dame
avec l'idée de mettre son de jouer
ensuite b6 b5 et de commencer à pousser
sa majorité de pions l'idée de garry
kasparov alors peut-être que barrière va
simplement reculer le fou
je ne sais pas ce qu'il va faire en deux
ou en d3 une des deux cases et ensuite
jouer b6 v5 c'est possible
alors qu'on nous demande les classements
des joueurs éliminés eh bien les demi
finalistes sont judit polgar et
alexander breach hook et alexander
leitch la révélation alors que maria
fait reculer son fou il a reconnu son
fou sur la case de 2 et la kasparov a
envoyé tempo un coup je crois qu'il a
joui caracas par la cave alliance et 6,6
il voulait sortir son cavalier c6 voilà
pourquoi kasparov a joué cet ordre de
coûts peut-être le match aura 5 saint lô
des glaces le pion c5 étant prises non
c'est ça qui est emprisonné depuis en c3
le serait aussi
donc ici est ce que pareil elle va
prendre ces cinq je ne crois pas ça
serait un aveu de faiblesse
positionnelle puisqu'il s'adresse entre
à garry kasparov là il tient bien le
centre et s'il prend ses 5 et bien
détruit lui-même son propre sens donc a
priori au niveau conceptuel c'est pas un
bon choix maintenant qu'est ce qu'il
peut faire d'autre et bien on peut lui
proposer tour b 1 sans doute qui est un
bon coup pour mettre la pression on peut
envisager des 5 mai non pas trop c'est
pas parce qu'on a envie de jouer des
cinq le plan bas relief dans cette
position quelque peu de cas peut-il être
stéphane peut-être tombé ensuite qui est
des deux noms fois vu de leurs cavaliers
d2 pour jour les claviers sur la casse
c4est faire pression sur b6 qui pour
l'instant la seule faiblesse d'un gant
noir ça ça paraît un plan possible en
tout cas barrière devrait commencer par
tour d un bilan pendule il reste 20e
minute à barrière et 17 à kasparov donc
quatre minutes d'avancé pour varier
c'est pas mal il peut réfléchir et
trouver un plan subtil tout à fait
positionnelle dans son style
rappelons que ben arieh fait des
secondes mains de vladimir kramnik comme
l'a rappelé jean claude matière aux
commentaires il était cependant delà des
murs kramnik lors de son match comme
kasparov match que qu'à gagner vadimir
kramnik donc peut-être que cette
ouverture était une préparation possible
c'est sûr lors du match de l'ombre dans
la parité utilisé mais non plus
aujourd'hui les caries kasparov a
renoncé à la défense grünfeld dès la
deuxième partie donc
vladimir kramnik n'a pas pu montrer
toutes ces préparations sur les doses
faibles puisque gary kasparov a bougé
vers une autre défense alors que la
ville utilise maintenant
systématiquement la greenwald contre
tous les adversaires qui ne sont pas
chronique donc ben arieh fonds fait
partie
votre réflexion de bahreïn
faut noter que c'est ça doit lui faire
peur kasparov que ce soit bas relief en
finale c'est être le joueur le plus
dangereux seconde l'endocrâne nick
joueur numéro 12 mondiale je crois sur
le chat peut-être numéro 10 il est
numéro 10 mondial aiea sur le chat nous
proposons le coutour b1 et bien c'est
effectivement celui que nous avons
mentionné comme étant un coup
intéressant c'est pas mal pour commencer
à mettre la pression sur le plan b 6 on
peut également empêcher de matelas tours
en c1 de toute façon il va falloir
enlever cette tour de 1 puisqu'elle est
en prise par le fou stéphane un peu en
permanence en s'équipant c'est qui qui
propose tombé 1 qui propose pour bien
sûr le chat voilà une bonne question
donc
on ne sait pas ne sais pas
alors on va voir
bas relief
on le voit d'ailleurs sur la droite de
l'échiquier en pleine réflexion
faudrait pas qu'il gaspille son avance
autant ce serait dommage
ça serait dommage qu'ils gardent pas ces
deux minutes d'avancé qu'il a il a
failli jouer là il a hésité bas relief
il est en pleine réflexion qu'est ce
qu'il va finir à mettre la pression au
tac à ses parents il a joué il a joué
les monsieur deux probablement mc2 un
petit coup de viviani bas relief quelle
est l'idée de secours déjà le premier
point c'est que ça lille et tours
détours maintenant sont interconnectés
donc elles peuvent coulisser sur la
première rangée comme elles veulent il
peut mettre une tour en d1 bientôt c'est
vrai que c'est une belle colonnes pour
la tour pourra mettre leur tour en bien
bas relief ne se presse pas il ne donne
pas encore la direction qu'il va donner
à ces pièces à son armée
c'est un coup souple stéphane un coup
sous plus tranquille qui laisse toutes
les opportunités ouvertes toutes les
possibilités
à noter que ce coût des cds justifiée
puisque tours s'est vite 2 garry
kasparov n'est pas possible puisque
l'option assisterez emprise donc il y
aurait fort confiant qu'ils
attaqueraient la tour le couteur s'est
vite été bon dans la mesure où ça
mettait une tour face à la dame et ça
c'est bien ça met de la pression mais il
ne peut pas le faire mais rica sport
c'est pour ça que j'aime ces deux là
qu'à ses deux avocats a été une bonne
case pour la dame blanche
elle n'est pas la mettre ailleurs
alors que là s'ajoutent technique
stéphane puisqu'on remarque que les
joueurs réfléchissent quand même
beaucoup il reste 15 minutes 40 à garry
kasparov et 18 minutes 40 à higuain di
maria fait n'ont joué que treize coups
ça veut dire qu'ils ont déjà réfléchi
donc dix minutes ils ont infléchi
presque 20 minutes à 2 e 2 pour jouer
très ce coup c'est beaucoup quand même
oui c'est beaucoup dans mon habitude un
rythme plus rapide ouais peut-être qu'on
va avoir droit rhin et note effrénée à
la fin
alors que la séquence par rohff qui
réfléchit décidément
c'est pas plus mal qu'ils réfléchissent
au début on aura droit à des salves de
coups rapides d'ici peu
c'est sûr il reste 15 minutes à kasparov
contre 10,8 et demi 18 37 exactement à
bas relief a noté stéphane qu'on a voulu
dire que garry kasparov était capable
effectivement de faire les salves de
coups comme tu le dis puisque contre
gries toucan beats il a été tout
simplement impitoyable n'a jamais laissé
great thou que reprendre son souffle il
lui a mis la pression autant il a joué
tout tempo il a tout envoyé garry
kasparov et donc il peut jouer très vite
et très bien
c'est confirmé le champion du monde est
très fort
dames c'est cette je crois mes amis
saddam on a joué dans cette voie là
karaté sport même idée il use il dit
c'est tout en question ça laisse un pion
ça laisse le pion ces cinquante années
ce que tous ces cinq ans prise mais ça
ne serait pas forcément bon de prendre
ses pions stéphane puisqu'à la fin est
bien bas relief aurait dû contre jeu sur
l'option c3 avec saddam ans et 7
donc on peut simuler une variante une
possibilité non ça jouer c'est à jouer
et la prudence et cinq barrières ya
princesse elle avait promis dans une
fois et maintenant il va peut-être
prendre du fou voilà ce qui vient de se
passer question critique critique
puisque la prison ses cinq effectivement
on l'a dit est une faute conceptuel ça
laisse le centre et il a joué au foot
français 5 il a fait faux procès sont
variés le pian il a pris le pian barrier
by c10 a vaincu enseignants il relève le
challenge je réfléchirai plus tard il a
pris le pian alors est-ce que kasparov a
justifié cette perte de pions pas sûr
pas sûr du tout le coup c'est pour
kasparov le coût attendu ces dames en
aura 5 qui attaque et le fou ces cinq
lots pioncer 3 tout ça pour faire nul
mais il y aurait encore du jeu ben arieh
four à l'initiative l'initiative
puisqu'il est sorti plus de pièces et
que le temps de kasparov reprenne
options et ça va lui coûter du temps
variable pour à remobiliser ses pièces
au centre avec une belle initiative
avantage bas relief dans cette partie
stefan wey petit avantage à bas relief
très léger on durable durable il faut
que kasparov damas cinq
dames 1 5 pour récupérer le pion c3 mais
ça va permettre aux blancs de développer
leurs pièces avec gain de temps voilà
effectivement on peut simuler une
variante stéphane
anosy pour la simulation d'un masque
faut avouer à 3 et la france et 3 par
exemple c3 ou d'un français 3 au choix
on va supposer qu'il prend du fou est là
au niveau 3 c'est rien suivi de tous
rêvent d improbables mais on voit que
les deux pièces attaque le fou le fou je
reviens au g7 et là on lui met la
deuxième tour en d1 et on voit que ces
barrières qui le premier sur les lieux
avec deux tours il attaque le fou menace
tout reprendre 17 même si lille nord le
protège puisque le cavalier c6 serait
alors en prise voilà tout à fait donc en
plus comme il ya le x 3 qui a un oeil
sur le turbo 7 eh bien ça commence à
faire beaucoup pour bien les kasparov
donc c'est tout le problème dans cette
position garry kasparov hésitent à jouer
damas cinq mais non il l'a fait
puisqu'il n'avait pas vraiment le choix
là-bas cinq on notera que sur food &
katz et famille un petit piège monsieur
hausse à 0,5 ouais enfin bon le fou le
fouillis perdu voilà ça nettoie santé
quatre sapeurs une pièce c'est dommage
parce que ça aurait été un bon coup
sinon c'est sûr ça aurait récupéré le
centre je pense que marié va pas
vraiment le choix donc il lui reste dix
sept minutes il a quatre minutes
d'avancé et il va je me fous à 3
tranquillement conservant son petit
avantage ilkin hibbard yapp il n'est pas
très connu du grand public en tout cas
mais c'est un super joueur superbe
joueur habitué de ce genre de thomas
élimination directe système coupe il a
les nerfs solides il a gagné deux fois
tilborgh on le rappelle il a été second
temps de la dîmière chronique il a
terminé vice champion du monde
à la coupe du monde deux parties lentes
effectivement donc on peut s'attendre à
tout de la part d'un tel joueur il est
capable de battre garry kasparov il
réfléchit bas relief là alors le
problème c'est que cette simplification
va donner des structures de pions et
symétriques un pur bras de chaque côté
et des pions en quatre points en deux 2
côtés roi des deux côtés donc ça va
s'acheminer vers la nulle oui mais alors
attention parce qu'il ya quand même de
l'initiative si garry kasparov n'arrive
pas à sauver toutes ces pièces puisqu'il
aura beaucoup de pièces emprise et bien
ce sera plus question de structure de
pions symétrique stéphane il sera
question de pièces de plus pour marc
hayek et ça ça s'achemine vers un gars
je pense qu'il est nettement mieux
équilibrée hier après le coup fourré 3
mais je veux x 3 de toute façon il a
l'air tout à fait tranquille x 3 on le
rappelle c'est ce goût ou c5 sur la case
à 3 et pour y réfléchit par ailleurs
après ce qu'il veut jouer il veut jouer
food et 4 quand même une intruse un
point bas peut-être qu'il veut jouer un
coup intermédiaire autour des 1 par
exemple pour attaquer le fou 17 c'est
sûrement ça
permettrait d'emprunter 5 d'un procès
cinq tours kung fu en fou et d'un
français 3 mais alors là stephen il ya
une contrepoint que je joue d'un
programme fut prompt et torcéen qui
récupère une pièce enfilant les pièces
en enfilade une enfilade en toute
simplicité
voilà donc le truc il a deux fois trois
mariages quand même
à trois et il garde un peu d'avancé
autant toujours deux minutes avant sa
barrière presque trois minutes
d'ailleurs et oui trois minutes avant sa
part eev prêcheur prêcheur sur le garry
kasparov mais la position quand même
très symétriques
ils menacent ces quatre bref
autour c'est un peut-être
penser qu'à tours c'est un moyen tour
5e' des champions plutôt tour c'est un
d'ailleurs si kasparov de propulsion le
prochain coup de barrière c'est la tour
anciens ensuite il pourra mettre le
cavalier en d4 éventuellement d'ailleurs
il peut le faire aussi tout de suite
c'est peut-être une de ces menaces et
oui avantage pareils fc est clair c'est
clair et net dans cette position
alors stéphane qu'en penses tu va-t-il
battre garry kasparov mais ça serait
bien pour le spectacle ça obligerait
kasparov a essayé de gagner avec les
blancs après mais on sait combien c'est
difficile de gagner une partie contre
kasparov c'est quasiment impossible
on a vu que kramnik en 16 parties a
réussi à gagner uniquement deux ça a
suffi puisqu'il n'a pas perdu mes deux
parties sur cèze c'est très peu et
chroniques et numéro deux mondial
est très dur à battre garry kasparov il
perd très très peu de parties même en
partie rapide
oui puisqu'on se rappelle des grands
prix intel que garry kasparov à gagner
régulièrement
c'était la terreur là-bas très très
difficile à battre est en tout cas ils
gagnent et variés n'a jamais réussi à
s'en sortir dans ces fameux tournoi
c'était toujours kasparov chronique et à
nantes alors que pour la hiérarchie
mondiale aux échecs stéphane le meilleur
joueur c'est probable kasparov en tout
cas des trois médias c'est kasparov
chronique et attendent très clairement
ils se sont détachés du reste des
joueurs et donc rami cannor descente à
monaco en ce moment et il domine le
tournoi facilement donc quand on prend
un de ses trois joueurs qu'on le fait
jouer dans un tournoi normal et bien ils
le gagnent quand ils jouent entre eux
c'est plus chaud
lagardère sports devrait logiquement
s'imposer dans cette finale mais la
position pour l'instant n'est pas du
tout à son avantage
la pendule non plus ouais bah relief à
trouver l'ouverture qui pose le plus de
problème un kasparov cinq minutes
d'altération de voir assis avec les
noirs par eev utilise la défense
berlinoise à l'influencé droit qu'à
utiliser kramnik kasparov a pris en c3
avec je prends la dame oui avec adams
l'ondam concrètement et rend
donc là
normalement evgeny bas relief devrait
reprendre d'un programme et après font
jouer tour sur la casse et un suivi de
tourner ensuite autour des 1 voilà ce
qu'on attend de bas relief une
mobilisation rapide de ces pièces
a ajouté qu'on se demande ce qui a vu
kasparov pour lutter contre ça stéphane
quand même
et ouais mais peut-être
un mode écoute simple de défense
suffisent à tenir la position enfin on
voit tout de suite aux problèmes
immédiats on va vous le mentionnez après
tom programme qui n'a pas encore été
jouée par mariette mais le sera sûrement
fouleront tour c1 est bien là si le fou
vient au g7 il semblerait que ça perdre
immédiatement après tour f d un
attaquant le fou 17 et le cas et c'est 6
donc si on défend faut se fout et 8 mois
là il faut jouer
il a joué il a joué dame prend dame il a
joué il a joué d'un problème bas relief
ça y est c'est fait d'apprendre à me fou
prend damas est évidemment dame kasparov
effectivement c'est le genre de coups
qu'il joue tempo et maintenant barrière
va jouer un tour à ses seins il n'a pas
vraiment le choix il y avait ni bas
relief
alors il réfléchit il réfléchit et oui
la wave 3 c'est un tour assez sains
alentour bien il n'a joué tour b 1 un
coup alternatif de bas relief un coup
alternatif à noter que bas relief il ne
fait pas d'attaquants un coup stéphane
oui il fait plutôt des attaques en
plusieurs points du fait des plans en
fait il fait des menaces de plan mais
pas d' attaque directe ou alors très peu
très curieux ce coup tombé 1 c'est un
style un peu introverti d'ailleurs signé
par ailleurs
vais changer une paire de tours barrière
je pense pas que ça soit son idée son
idée c'est surtout de rentrer sur la 7e
la question c'est si kia soir je tombais
vite et bien qu est ce qu il a vu barise
voilà ce qu'on peut se demander
c'est là que on a du mal à comprendre ah
oui oui il ya le pion à 600 prises c'est
ça l'idée stéphane fouet deux attaques
le pion à 6 c'est ça le truc c'est que
sur tourbe invités bien on prend des 8es
après le pion à 6 cette emprise mais il
faut prendre du cavalier oui mais prend
du cavaly c'est pas très bonnes aubaines
puis en recettes et en prise fabuleux
fabuleux barrières d'options aux 7 et le
pion à 6 ça fait deux options aux prises
ce qui fait que son coût tourbains prend
une efficacité nouvelle garry kasparov
ne peut pas l'empêcher de rentrer sur
les 15-17 avec la tour et on sait qu'une
tour sur la septième rangée stéphane
sait capable de faire des miracles un
ouais pas mal ce qu'a trouvé par eev
pas mal du tout tous rêvent v8 de
kasparov quand même kasparov oui il est
obligé ils jouent très très actif
ce qu'il a oublié quelque chose barrail
est qu'elle soit enfin joué le coup
positionnelle qu'on attendait on
s'achemine vers la nuque bilan pendule
14 minutes restantes pour barnier a fait
10 pour kasparov ce qui est horrible à
kasparov c'est qu'on ne le voit pas se
tromper on pense pas qu'il ne puisse se
tromper
tous rêvent et vite normalement il
devrait y avoir tout reprend tour
et tout reprend tour
et surtout prend 1,6 kasparov a sans
doute vu quelque chose
pour mon tour stéphane c'est ce coup il
y aurait tout reprend tour également et
le fonds à six et après on se demande ce
qui se passe alors content il reste
treize minutes à barrière contre 10
minutes à kasparov c'est bien un bas
relief arrive à maintenir kasparov à
distance autant ça c'est très important
une garde la pression il y avait ni
barrière a noté stéphane que nous sommes
quand même en finale du championnat du
monde et que c'est un moment très chaud
en très chaud puisque cicas porte ne
gagne pas et bien ça fait longtemps
qu'il n'aura pas gagné de tournoi
homologué stefan wey 7e 14e des tournois
privés
alors qu'on nous signale que caster
gigote voilà si on peut le voir en grand
la c'est vrai que c'est plutôt curieuse
que fait garry kasparov il gigote alors
il a arrêté de bouger mais enfin il a la
tête rentrée dans les épaules
si on n'est pas du duce garry kasparov
ici stéphane s qui ne se demande pas où
la cei essayé qui gesticule
c'est quand même un beau spectacle
devrait quitter ce procès c'est toujours
plaisant à voir stéphane des images de
guerre in
by f ils envoyaient il a pris un tour il
a pris là tout ça y est on va enfin
savoir ce qui se passe est une
classement fois répondu tempo par trop
un tour aussi donc qu'entourer
évidemment la caisse barrière devrait
prendre le pion à 6 avec son four
évidemment sinon ne se passe plus rien
car ils se passeraient une foule cavale
et b4 surtout prend 1,6 à wade qui avait
quatre c'est une possibilité c'est sans
doute ce qu'a bulgarie kasparov avec
vraisemblablement comme tu l'as dit
stéphane une nulle en perspective et
tout ça n'est pas fait pour arranger le
public
ça arrange en revanche garry kasparov
qui avec les blancs pour l'instant gagné
pratiquement toutes ses parties
et que chris schott qui a réussi à tenir
dans les parties semi rapide
que chiu qu'on le rappelle n'a que 17
ans un lots de 2660 superbe joueur le
meilleur junior du monde actuellement
est-ce qu'il va prendre ce pion à 6 bas
relief
s'est pas complètement sûr stéphane
ce qu'ils veulent prendre à pavie à s'il
le prend à pré carré les b4 s'achemine
vers la nulle
c'est tout le problème
oui
nous allons donc simuler
simulons le coup franc à six stéphane il
peut y avoir cavaliers b4
comme tu l'as dit attaque le fou et
attaque le pion alors maintenant la
question c'est que se passe-t-il sur fu
panda 4 ça donne la paire de fou ça
donne la paire de fou mais si on peut
conserver notre camp plus ce sera une
bonne octobre à 34 il y aura
malheureusement tout combat quatre
attaques le pion à 4 elle ne peut pas
être défendue puisque vous avez le fou
au c3 contrôler la casa 1 pour la tour
il peut avancer mais là il ya tour à 4
et à cette fois ci le pion va
définitivement être mangé ouais donc
voilà tout le problème de barrières dans
cette position c'est que s'il prend le
plus raciste suit une variante force et
avec quelle idée 4 qui attaquent le fois
l'option qui récupère le pion pour garry
kasparov donc on peut supposer que tours
b 1 n'était pas le bon coup puisque la
barrière réfléchi apparemment il ne
trouve pas grand chose et donc s'il ne
trouve pas stéphane qu'est ce qu'il va
faire mais il va faire partie nulle il
va faire partie de la vie c'est ça le
c'est ça le truc c'est dommage on ya cru
on a cru que barrière pouvait pas de cas
sport dans cette première partie ce qui
lui aurait donné un énorme ascendant
psychologique dans la deuxième ce qui
les aurait pu lui permettre de battre
kasparov mais là s'il ne fait que nul
avec les blancs et bien on a déjà vu
d'autres joueurs se faire se faire
battre comme ça
c'est très chaud
c'est très très chaud alors que là nous
avons grandi et vieilli bas relief le
finaliste de cette coupe du monde
d'échecs contre garry kasparov
finalistes également
pour l'instant on ne sait pas qui est
champion du monde mais c'est un de ces
deux joueurs champions du monde de
parties rapides bien sûr stéphane
sur les pièces de l'échiquier et parce
qu'on a d'autres propositions pour
revivre des nibards hayef
mettrai peut que t'être tourne autour
des 1 peut-être pour attaquer le fou 17
le coutour f1 en d1 et ça permettrait
pouces et 8 peut-être qui protège le
pion à 6 voilà fou s'est vite protège le
pion à et là il n'y a plus vraiment
davantage pour parer diafi là il
n'aurait pas dû céder le centre sans
doute thierry liebart eev n'aurait pas
dû céder les quatre centrales coiffure
vous c'est lui qui à tour c'est un qui
attaque de pièces
tout à fait mais il y aurait sans doute
trouvé les quatre femmes et quatre
autres au métro ou tour b3 qui
défendrait tout en contre attaquant donc
ici le coût soit tour d un soin fonds à
six les deux ont l'air de produits hier
à la nulle il est possible il est
possible que bach hayat propose une dans
cette position pourquoi et bien parce
que la structure des pions et symétrique
il n'y a pas davantage matériel il n'y a
pas davantage de développement la
pression des rois est à peu près
équivalente donc tous les facteurs étant
équivalent on peut dire que la pression
est égal et donc évidemment à ce niveau
de la compétition
quand la position est égal eh bien ça ne
se joue plus à noter que paris a fait
passer sous kasparov à la pendule
puisque harry huit minutes 45 et 10
minutes 14 à garry kasparov et oui ça
fait un moment qui réfléchit barrière
fois
il se demande s'il peut obtenir un
avantage ou alors finir la partie par
fou prend 1,6 durant 100 dos demande ce
qu'on pense du coup tour c'est un
stéphane
et bien tour c'est évidemment et sur le
chat c'est un pseudonyme ce n'est pas
quelqu'un ce n'est pas un joueur ce
n'est pas un grand maître a priori non
mais enfin il nous propose ce coup le
coup tour c'est un attaque le fou c3 et
il y aurait tour b3 et donc là stéphane
tu proposes de couture b3 probablement
qui protège le fouet à taper x 3 protège
le fou attaque le fou pas mal pas mal ce
coup peut-être que tour 6 1 est un bon
moyen de conserver un petit avantage
on verra bien si mariage ou secouer bien
pour féliciter guronsan
depuis onze ans de 11 ans qui est donc
le nom d'un célèbre médicament dont nous
usons et abusant à canal web
à diagonale seulement précise
effectivement c'est vrai mais là donc
c'est de l'événementiel tout ça c'est
très chaud le direct en direct de cannes
quand même sur le grand auditorium
donc tout reprend p8 tout reprendre et
vite
barrail f qu'est ce qu'il peut faire
dans cette position il ya plus que 7
minutes 30 ça va pas là ça va pas si
marielle fait trop le malin s'il va
chercher trop loin une solution est bien
la situation peut se retourner stéphane
caristan faut carrément l'emporter alors
là ce serait désastreux
non il va jouer on sent une proposition
de noël de bach à y prendre un avion à 6
francs à six mois il va proposer nul
sans doute ils gagnent bas relief k&b 4
évidemment garry kasparov qui l'a vu
kasparov 15 km et 4 tempo ouais
et là qu'est ce qui se passe il
semblerait que la nuls soit forcé change
barriac prend b4 et joue faux b5 c'est à
dire que ça donnerait cela ce n'est pas
joué pour le moment pour vous prouver
5-fu prends mes 5 puis on prend b 5
tours combes et 5 et l'anru stéphane une
structure symétrique quatre pions contre
4 il n'y a pas de purs éloigner les plus
éloignés un petit avantage aux fous oui
mais là il y en a pas donc ça c'est
complètement nul tout à fait donc ici
après québec adq ou de kasparov et bien
là nul devrait être signé rapidement
phare l'ipad fait de partir on ne signe
pas c'est une expression symbolique mais
là nul devrait être conclue entre les
deux joueurs pour cette première demi
finale pour cette première partie de la
finale stéphane la seconde fait brasser
des matches en deux parties
et voilà
voyons y être réfléchis y aurait six
minutes contre 10 minutes à kasparov
mais il faut qu'il fasse attention
barrière va pas se laisser distancer
quand même trop autant même si la
position va être facile à jouer oui la
position soit facile à jouer ne sera
sans doute pas joué par gary castor je
pense qu'il n'a pas envie de gagner
comme ça gary de toute façon on ne
pourrait pas gagner voilà il va jouer va
proposer nul là ça se sent on l'a lu sur
son visage marief
fous ces quatre et non il va jouer il va
jouer il va jouer bach haydn
kasparov a pris en a quatre quelle est
l'idée qu'elle est l'idée il ne faut pas
qu'ils s'enflamment barrières quand même
il faut pas qu'ils s'enflamment ici
peut-être non c'est complètement égal ça
c'était fans c'est complètement égal il
peut y avoir tour c'est un qui attaquent
le foot est roi où alors tour b1 qui
clora lecavalier mais dans tous les cas
on voit mal quel sport se tromper la
position étant égale donc ici
je ne vois pas ce que peut faire yevgeny
bas relief en tout cas il fait nul
contre garry kasparov c'est pas un
mauvais résultat en soi non c'est pas
mauvais mais il va falloir tenir mais
les pièces noires après c'est tout le
problème tenir avec les pièces noires et
ensuite tenir en bits oui ce qui est pas
facile non plus mais tenir c'est pas
gagné et oui qui n'avance pas recule
c'est là tout le problème
vous ces quatre fous prend 1,4 les deux
derniers coups de cette partie et garry
kasparov on voit pas ce qui peut
l'inquiéter maintenant et bas relief n'a
plus que quatre minutes 40 kasparov dix
minutes donc on voit une superbe gestion
du temps de garry kasparov qui a
réfléchi longtemps quand il avait des
problèmes et une fois qu'il n'en a plus
maintenant ils jouent tous tempo ces
barrières qui réfléchit pour trouver des
chances assez facile kasparov de cette
partie quand même un oui oui
on sent un petit coup sud une
proposition nul non non ok je croyais ce
n'est pas de cette trempe là
ne proposera sans doute pas nul concédé
à jouer pour ce tour c'est un
attaque le fou ces trois attaques le
foot est roi le foot doit bouger on ne
peut pas protéger ce fou il va donc
repartir vraisemblablement f6 et si
c'est une bonne case pour le fond
puisque de la
muzelle le cavaliere 3 qui ne peut plus
aller nulle part oui et en plus
affronter jeu set et en plus ça protège
le pion aux 7 c'est un excellent choix
peut-être que il a vu ça variait faille
sur fou ici ce qui est une possibilité
gaspard va sûrement jouer il va jouer
tourbe et un fort sens plus ou moins là
nul soit pas repoussé trois encore une
fois soit par cavalia si ce
qui fera du log également donc ici de
toute façon pas de problème quel gars si
ce qui change les tours donc et puis
après c'est nul en souplesse on revient
sur la position
kaspi a joué fouet f6
les jouer le faux f6 fortis dans cette
position s'est fait sur quoi parader à
jouer tour b 1 voilà comme on l'a dit et
l'annuler conclut ça y est c'est fait il
a proposé une barrière kasparov est
parti en courant nulle conclu pas mal
pour bas relief une aussi facile quand
même de kasparov l'a pas une si bonne
nouvelle pour garry kasparov stéphane
pas une si bonne nouvelle
on va bientôt rendre l'antenne
effectivement mais il y à la deuxième
partie qui commencera stéphane à partir
de 16h donc à partir de 15h55 on
commence le direct ici
et ça va être chaud ça va être chaud là
cette fois votre lui kasparov là ne se
contente pas de nu le rapide kasparov
quand ils allaient blanc c'est autre
chose c'est autre chose il est là pour
faire très mal alors que la salle est en
train de se vider et nous voyons des
stars qui sortent en jetant un petit
agneau roi pascal villalba de nods haye
qui est ce que nous voyons d'autres et
bien
nous voyons
un arbitre un arbitre enfin ça c'est pas
les plus grandes stars si je me tourne à
ma gauche il y a dans la cabine de
commentaires laurent frayssinet joël
lautier jean-luc chavanon qui vous ont
fait ces commentaires qui nous fait des
commentaires dans la salle pendant que
nous le faisons pour le net
moi je crois qu'on peut ce qui t'es là
ils vont rester là alors je vous donne
rendez-vous m'a tout de suite sur le
chat puisque je vais venir dialoguer
avec vous quelques instants si vous avez
des questions bien précises bien
particulière eh bien je me ferais un
plaisir d'y répondre donc quoi dire
d'autre mise à part a tout de suite et
on se donne rendez-vous pour le direct à
partir de
15h55 pour laval au match retour qui
sera suivie par la remise des prix à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
m
je
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tes gonal
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs pour la super finale du
championnat du monde deux parties
rapides à cannes avec aujourd'hui iossif
dorfman bonjour diot cif bonjour on
rappelle que tu as été entraîneur de
castres or pendant des années oui dans
un premier temps que tu as été champion
de france en 98 à méribel de tout ça et
que donc ici que maintenant tu habites à
cannes donc tu es ici chez toi oui c'est
chez moi j'ai fait en dix ans j'ai
bénéficié depuis 11 ans donc ça commence
à faire un bout de temps donc la coupe
du monde à cannes sur le chat il ya
beaucoup de gens qui nous demandent
quels sont les pronostics actuellement
pour cette deuxième partie barrière
castor
normalement kasparov par le grand favori
déjà il joue avec les blancs et
deuxièmement au bar est vrai il ya le
score terrible contre kasparov mais
c'est les parties rapides et tout cas je
vais parce qu'à mon avis c'est doux
jurent qu'ils ont j'ai mis quelques
riches aussi qu'ils ont jugée en
fonction de situations sur l'échiquier
n'ont pas pris de risques stupide et ces
raisons j'ai osé cette classique est
pour cette raison que j'attends avec
impatience évidemment cette rencontre
oui ça va être très intéressant vont
effectivement garry kasparov et favoris
on a vu qu'avec les blancs il a beaucoup
de facilité jusqu'à maintenant oui parce
que ils travaillent beaucoup plus que
les autres saisons à l'est sont beaucoup
plus profondes incomparable et pour
tenir contre lui c'est pas évident
les gens n'osent pas jeu contre les
lignes moderne autrement c'est très
difficile a nécessité alors un pronostic
d'ouverture pour cette partie des sports
par les femmes donc les ados celles ci
ont aidé à carreaux carneglia la
française bien sûr si je suis à la plage
des bars et où je joue la française
c'est leur solide en tout cas pareils
est fabien battu jeudi pôle gare en demi
finale on joue à une française oui elle
est elle a joué un coup très très
bizarre un coup de dames dans
l'ouverture dans le dos et même après
c'était cd rendre certains mais la malle
avant de sceller puis on est allé
autrement pendant que le ca les rois par
jacques inter je sens qu etc mais elle a
raté le sun qui te définis immédiatement
d'accord donc là tout de suite on va
commencer cette cette émission le
générique va partir donc ivry du bas
relief contre garry kasparov par
kasparov avec les blancs partie très
très chaud donc on va pouvoir lancer le
générique est commencée proprement cette
finale
[Musique]
voilà c'est parti alors alors qu'on nous
demande sur le tchat s'il ya des chances
que ben arieh faut la défense berlinoise
je ne sais pas puisque tout le monde est
fan de vladimir kramnik et sa défense
berlinoise les français en redemandent
et veulent savoir ce que kasparov a
trouvé dessus
c'est difficile à répondre parce que
j'ai travaillé récemment avec un des
messages sur la berlinoise et là bas
elle est à cinq ou six défense
différente où les aider sans différentes
également et
on ne peut pas dire en quelques phrases
il faut il faut déjà savoir la méthode
du joug et il faut être très concret
très concrets dans les détails donc
c'est difficile à expliquer c'est
difficile de jouer dans le noir contre
kasparov quand on n'est pas sur un petit
show surtout après le match de
championnat du monde vous pouvez laisser
reprendre la première fois mais
maintenant elle a travaillé quelques
mois environ et c'est un grand risque
arrivé tout effet alors que là il ya de
l'animation sur scène beaucoup
d'animations la partie va bientôt
commencer ça va être une fille en deux
parties et vous savez ce que concerne la
berlinoise si c'est déjà fait dans
l'hommage du chagrin du monde c'est très
difficile de travailler avec les
ordinateurs pour un travail et les
détails tandis que si vous avez un cas
après quelques semaines ou quelques mois
donc c'est pas du tout la manne risque
aujourd'hui donc ça paraît effectivement
très dangereux de rejouer cette
berlinoise contrôle garry kasparov ou
évidemment c'est clair
donc dans la base aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas d'exemple de comprendre compte pas
encore mais ça va venir
déjà à l'époque ramener g et qu'elle
arrêtait de jouer c'est vrai oui oui
tandis qu'il ya trouvé un nouveau truc
c'est sur une sixième c'est sa
seigneurie congrès chioukh c'est pas
nouveau finalement ils jouent les trucs
qui étaient à la mode et les 30-40 ans
qui était répétée depuis longtemps mais
je ne vois pas les nouveautés
franchement et donc c'est toujours
réfuté les gens quand nos meilleurs rire
vaut arriver ou kasparov et leur attaque
à valeo 3 s'il jouait les cônes roman et
de change des taux aux études d'autres
lots dont il faut échanger les taux les
taux visé cette finale
en tout cas nous tous qui s'y fait une
grosse impression à cannes nocifs est ce
que tu peux nous en dire plus sur ce
joueur finalement peu connu qui n'a que
17 ans et qui se glisse dans l'élite
mondiale
oui les traits de et il a joué quand
j'étais l'entraîneur de mouscron
lors des championnats du monde du jaune
j'ai vu que le chiot que je me souviens
une fois
il a joué contre eux tiennent ils
avaient un net avantage matière n'est
trouvée
s'en sortir et même le bateau mais c'est
typique pour les russes pour les gens de
rimouski le progrès est un petit peu
plus au plus tard que les joueurs
occidentaux ce qui est là bas elle est
là manque de moyens les entraîneurs d or
dentaire et caetera et le vrai nom comme
chez pendant mario boucher très chaud
comme peut voir à partir de l'âge de 16
17 ans elle devient déjà un adulte alors
on nous demande enfin on me demande de
rappeler des qualités donc iossif
dorfman grand maître international
depuis des années
depuis 75 ans comme ça
77 donc plus de vingt ans d'un titre de
grand maître donc tu as été champion de
russie également 77 ans 77 donc
maintenant tu habites à cannes depuis
une dizaine d'années tu as été
entraîneur de kasparov champion de
france en 98 donc un palmarès élogieux
et surtout maintenant tu es un
entraîneur connu et reconnu avec des
élèves quand même
j'ai commencé
bon j'ai travaillé le même récemment
veut directeur pas l'orgueil fade et les
autres alors que je crois que jean
claude labat hier est en train de parler
donc on va peut-être écouté ce qu'il
nous raconte
maintenant
on va est donc immédiatement après les
bliss même chose remise de la coupe
voilà on vous demande vraiment donc de
nous faire confiance de rester avec nous
c'est un moment particulièrement
important qu'on vivre qu'on va vivre
donc cette partie commence on sait pas
quand est-ce qu'elle va se terminer bon
c'est à peu près les dates on sait qu'il
ya en gros 50 minutes potentiel mais ça
peut se terminer beaucoup plus
rapidement ça peut se terminer par tout
de suite la remise de la coupe et là on
a vraiment besoin de vous faudra vous
fassiez une ovation au joueur qui a
gagné et à celui qui a si magnifiquement
défendu ses chances en finale on vous
retrouve donc à l'issue de ce match
merci
voilà c'est reparti c'est reparti sur le
plateau de diagonale avec
iossif dorfman donc toujours avec mon
cabinet pour commenter cette ce deuxième
match de la finale donc garry kasparov
kenny bas relief ça va commencer bientôt
ça va être très chaud
alors on me demande quelles sont les
meilleures d'ouverture pour le nom en
partie rapide c'est une question quand
même un petit peu
généraliste donc ceux ci statue je pense
que tu es fan de la cécilienne
oui non mais aujourd'hui je joue car
comme de temps en temps de l'espagnol
mais ça dépend de d'arsenal barréjot
uniquement la française et caracole ne
peux pas je la cite surtout qu'on ne
cache pas donc oui on peut pas rêver
aujourd'hui
les joueurs sont arrivés sur scène
evgeny barrière est là en premier garry
kasparov n'est pas encore arrêtée et
donc comme d'habitude il y a une masse
de journalistes qui se met devant la
scène donc ça c'est une organisation
toujours très travaillé alors que
bahreïn
est installé avec les pièces noires
quand on voit la griffe espoirs qui
arrive toujours comme un boxeur aussi
fade away un vrai boxeur ida on a une
présence sur l'échiquier qui est tout à
fait considérable et les à une physique
bien sûr et c'est sans trop le 13 août
prochain
je les ai vus à l'âge de 18 ans voilà
sont en train de charger 13 ans qui
courait en plein soleil à la nage est
quelqu'un que l'amateur tous les jours
fait jogging
c'est un athlète nord et de la mer oui
c'est un véritable la tête on peut dire
qu'elles sont niveau les échecs sont
réellement un sport de compétition un
sport de haut niveau alors que la partie
va bientôt commencer
effectivement
ça va être
ça va être très chaud cette partie très
très chaud le titre de champion du monde
deux parties rapides alors via si c'est
un titre qui est pas vraiment reconnue
comme ce titre de champion du monde deux
parties rapides
oui c'est un petit piano vaut mais ça va
venir peut-être à 22h on ne va rien nous
a même les tournois qualificatifs pour
participer oui c'est ça c'est très
intéressant nation et parce que c'est
pas toujours qui les gère le mieux
classé donne avec la cadence classique
et sans les plus forts dans des parties
rapides et au contraire et là en
l'occurrence oui c'est qu'il ya trois
joueurs qui sont largement plus fort que
les autres c'est kasparov a indiqué anne
ondes ça je pense que tu es d'accord là
dessus ou et dont il a pris rapidement
en partie rapide oui en partie rapide
était en partie longue de toute façon
oui si certains c'est ce que vous
attendez
donc une partie 25 minutes par joueur
c'est parti kasparov qui ouvre avec le
pouilleux quatre rassemblements ou la
l'échiquier et la france dans lequel
française vient de minage cour à
l'ouverture je pense qu'elle va répéter
les bars et aux impacts annonc validé
nos cases parole n'a pas enlevé une
française à qui des deux normales choqué
c'est troy garity oui parce que
contraire ça n'a pas été très clair à
mon avis il a bien que je apparaît
donc la découpe se déroule très
rapidement on va avoir affaire actions
isolées ici vous et bien sûr celle
session d'ouverture le corps et s'y
colle et blanc ne peut pas attendre
de tenir un grand avantage en dessous
pour la misère mais ce sera une partie
est longue tout simplement parlé à
certains grands experts de cette
position oui un des meilleurs du monde à
mannheim correctionnel évidemment aussi
oui oui c'est cantona une référence sur
la française alors que les joueurs
jouent très très vite les premiers coups
donc évidemment c'est très connu l'idée
de toucher 5 c est en principe de passer
le fond j'ai trois pour les changer mais
il faut prendre cette parfois parce que
dans cette position où il est lé casse
avec les appuis pour les cavaliers
surtout la casse des katas pour les
cavaliers blanc on peut donner le faux
contre les cavaliers dans l'élection de
se joindre à la chorale et à semble
parfois plus important que le foie quand
on a des casses porte on peut
éventuellement donateurs de plus c'est
exactement la pression d'une des parties
du monde match contre gaulle qu à
l'époque ied au célèbre match changeait
au mois de janvier de 78 jeux avec les
blancs et gpu en un set je me sens bien
j'ai donné les fonderies commons c'est
très très légèrement mieux peut-être
pour la demande donc à petit avantage
symbolique pour kasparov pour l'instant
à noter qu'au niveau des temps de
réflexion et bien ces barrières qui
réfléchit en premier donc peut-être que
se coule un peu surpris je ne sais pas
pas vraiment non je ne crois pas il faut
s'adapter à
ce que ce soit et et comprendre qu'elle
apparaît t elle a commencé a déjà manqué
une mise en forme en fait je sentais
mise en condition préparation pour la
partie donc là coûts attendues pour bas
relief qu'est ce qu'on pourrait dire
peut-être dans cette zone au polaroïd sa
décrue cavaliers le plan des noirs dans
cette position en quelques mots enfin
les idées générales c'est ne pas changer
de pièce pousser les pions
donc c'est les pions ne compte pas
passer les biomes on essaie un petit peu
de céder à la pression du roi blanc avec
fuji quote part dans ce set affaiblir h3
parfois et les blancs pour mettre le fou
ces lits dont 2,4 parfois cinq fois en
k2 dames ce site comme ça te rendre
guide cavale et f5 et c'est donc
normalement c'est le combat pour la case
des cats devant le plan désolé mais en
ce moment là le blanc contrôle
parfaitement cette case oui pour
l'instant c'est vrai que kasparov a
placé ses pièces de façon idéale on voit
les deux cavaliers la dame les deux fous
qui sont bien avancés d'ailleurs ces
fonds provenant être amené à reculer je
ne sais pas le foot et 5 pour l'instant
salaire un petit peu curieux non mais il
peut revenir l'important ici vous
jacques est avant qu'un message a même
fait eu d'eau c'est évident qu'elle est
allée f des créateurs pour échanger les
pillages les sur la simplification sens
favorable pour le blanc donc tous les
échanges de pièces c'est bien pour les
normands le mauvais mouais tout à fait
donc qu'est ce qu'on peut dire pour
l'instant on peut peut-être regarder la
tête de gary kasparov
puisque le voilà garry kasparov
est-ce qu'on peut le voir en peut-être
un peu plus grand
voilà toujours très présent chez pas
cillé qu'est ce qu'on regarde quel sport
fait beaucoup de biblique de de crime un
sens fait aussi part faut c'est un
acteur tout simplement un jour pour le
public oui tout à fait c'est c'est en
fait ça n'a rien à voir avec la position
ce qui fait non évidemment une fois il
ne faut pas réagir sur ses grimaces
puisqu'il fait il fait exprès très
souvent ouais vous pensez que vous avez
donné une pièce parfois
après sélection oui mais votre cou est
absolument mieux d'accord avec les
tanks et les jeunes
le flashcode maintenant on surnomme ses
sept fous je trouve
et s'il est en vie dans ces sept le four
à revenir sur laquelle j'ai trois pour
s'échanger oui changé après comme
l'élève décode le fou il reviendra
quelques pages en ado en d3 légèrement
nous pour le blanc jean-louis toi tu
préfère largement cette pression était
blanc comme légèrement mais d'accord
donc plus sur sept et si je sais pas je
ne peux pas chanter pas conseillé il
faut prendre cette français d'après fo
f6 mais ça va parler noir d'un v6 vous
êtes si c'est une personne très agréable
donc évident qu'il va faire flasher 4g
fou 1 3 et 6 htc est encore utile donc
faut 3 pourquoi pourquoi feu si cette
eau avec la tour nord une fois jusqu'à
tard évidemment il faut prendre ces six
d'andry un baisser et les noirs améliore
la position il faut penser si ça aurait
été un coup intermédiaire mais
effectivement les noirs quand ils
reprennent avec l'option se retrouve à
défendre leur pays isolés dont qu'ils
améliorent leur structure de pions ils
ont pris la paire de fou donc à ce qu'on
les y aurait plus de plus de soucis le
coup qu'on attend c'est fois je tape
donc il n'a pas encore été jouée par les
castors nous sommes c'est pratiquement
france mais léo est a priori je sais pas
je sais pas qu'est ce qu'elle cherche
chinois
mais pourquoi elle est pourquoi elle
réfléchit parce que h6 s'est pas encore
gic le fou il se déplace en g3 est
normalement c'est le projet de plan de
relance 5 avec cette idée est donc il
réfléchit pour comprendre pourquoi son
adversaire joue à 6 c saatchi c'est un
coup curieux en fait c'est ça surprend
un peu kasparov c'est pour ça qu'il n'y
pas pas tout de suite
se placer comme il avait envie de faire
à la limite on peut penser donc un
public ils avaient prévu deux fois
jusqu'à tes foucher 3 même si maria ce
job machine tout simplement
donc qu'est-ce par le palais par exemple
sur flash 4 on ne peut pas faire d'un v6
pour gagner du temps il faut jeter de
ses jouets voilà c'est de dire
maintenant d'être dams à cette
nécessaire parce que si on joue d'un v6
il y avoue prendre ces six ne
relâchaient de prendre deux cavaliers
d'emprunter sont gagnantes pions c'est
une simulation d'un v6 ce n'est pas joué
on ne monte pas le faire puisque faut
prouver ça il faut france et six bien
sûr oui il faut prendre de coraline est
d'environ 200 gagne le pylône je ne vois
pas tout à fait comme excuse de calvi et
ont prises par la tour et par le foot il
faudrait bien donc normaux ce dernier
set
non d'investissement comme sictom c7 est
attendu c'est pour aia jour où j'écris
une info jacques au être un beau coup de
dé veloppement brand le réflexe le
premier réflexe foe d'eau on a des fois
au dos pour jet cavale et f des catalans
coup suivant d'accord en fait tout ça
toujours pour changer des pièces seront
évidemment il n'y a aucun n'y a aucun
bloc dans cette position les blancs
veulent tout est changé donc food le
réflexe on va voir si kasparov jeux
seront donc finalement est-ce qu'on a
une explication à ce coup à 7 h is you
cif qui donc est curieux au gtp interdit
quelque part pour pour jouer cavalier f5
un jour peut-être mais comment on peut
réussir je répète sur d'un bassiste jeu
il ya faut prendre ce si long pour moi
c'est pas évident oui
comment on peut faire peut-être dans
dix-sept paradoxal pas d'âme soeur
mesdames 17 qui va menacer qu'edf 50
jours il va je fous je trouve a de toute
façon même que donc c'est dur à
expliquer
simplement
cauchemar à mon avis il y a il a gardé
deux jours le fond je sens que le faux
glande pour pouvoir chez m6 si c'est
nécessaire pour gagner du temps mais
quand je me souviens sa partie contre
gibbs ne savais pas à quel jeu quand je
rêve si ce n'est pas tout signe de dos
d'âne ou un moment donné on peut faire
dame décédée m6 et trop vite pour
achever le développement
vite encore jeune et grand spécialiste
de cette ouverture mais malheureusement
on n'est pas là ce soir il s'agit de bas
relief et et garry kasparov donc
toujours un très bon match donc si vous
avez des questions je rappelle que
voulez vous pouvez les poser sur le
tchat en direct tout de suite les
questions sont transmises en cabine de
commentaire donc si vous avez des
questions pour iossif dorfman quand on
connaît son palmarès on a forcément des
choses à lui demander et bien posé lui
vous répondra donc avec tout son talent
et toutes ses connaissances
il paraît que feu de haie est
pratiquement nécessaire bien sûr un pur
inséré h3 mais dans ce cas là le fond ne
revient pas en g3 donc ramona food est
nécessaire autrement on ne peut pas se
battre pour la cause des cats on peut
passer par exemple comme hervé descottes
parce que quand on va les prendre des
cadres obligé de prendre avec la dent il
faut prendre trois alors attends que
j'avais mal et je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
tout à fait suivi du psg d'ici les
foules non non j'ai dit si on ne joue
pas faut donc commencer par carrier bd
car oui comme les prendre des cadres
obligé de prendre avec la dame aux
profiteurs et noir sont bien d'accord
donc donc au dos jeudi pratiquement
obligé je ne vois pas comment pour
progresser il faut pas toucher à fait
noir sont bien ici c'est la lettre les
structures il faut casser la pression du
roi du roi surtout voilà donc ce n'est
pas de ça c'est pas une option donc pour
l'instant en fait le coup j'ai quatre
évite le coût qualité des cadres des
blancs on est donc la proposition de
nocif c'est fou 2 et après que relève t4
et après cavaliers fdk donc vallaurio
s'il déjà des réactions sur le tchat les
gens te remercie d'être là ne te
remercie de leur donner des conseils et
donc ça y est j'ai une question pourquoi
kasparov a joué aux quatre
je vais vous le dire avant de son
premier recours que il faut envisager
des cadres également mais dernière dont
kasparov il est un adepte de e4 et à mon
opinion euro iv c'est pas la ressource
est absolument idéal aujourd'hui idées à
quelques grands de la scène ou
d'espagnol je ne vois pas aucun avantage
pour les blancs mais paris ne juge pas
ni la ccja ligne l'espagnol est contre
la française à caracas a beaucoup plus
facile d'obtenir davantage de comptes ni
yo-yo au gré d'un et c'est là mon
idée c'est l'explication mais quand même
quel sport pourrait profiter en fait en
tout cas pour cette partie contre bas
reliefs du répertoire donc déjà dans
l'ue ce qui n'est pas complètement
efficaces kiné qui n'a pas un bon choix
de variantes a priori enfin en tout cas
il les connaît très bien et là ça
réfléchit beaucoup alors il reste 22
minutes a varié fait 19 à kenscoff donc
kasparov réfléchit plus que son
adversaire pour l'instant est-ce que
c'est à dire qu'il est aussi lui aussi
enfin il est lui aussi en train d'entrer
dans la partie de se préparer non je ne
crois pas kasparov d'épée des années
déjà comme con car par l époque ils
essaient de percer la pression adverse
en ouverture ils essaient de gagner
pratiquement la partie en ouverture il
ne cherche pas un très léger avantage
pour le développer vendre en complétant
et ici on ne voit pas même si vous
faites photo il vous fait cavalier fdk
tape l'auteur elle pu revenir avec le
fond dessert il faut ramasser les atouts
pas par exemple je peux vous donner une
idée vous faites sur le dos je pus j'ai
par exemple j'ai position oui par
exemple je que je le coup comme assise
pour éviter après que des cadres comme
les baies 5 plus tard d'accord i /
kovalev décote par exemple je pu revenir
même à mon avis avec le fou 17 pour ne
pas changer maintenant le cavalier
embêteront n'est pas très bien placé il
pour progresser que faire c'est aux
prénoms c6 je baissais et 7e positions
seulement un certain temps seront alors
je me rappelle de plomb qui sont
jouables pour les noirs des fonds joue
avec à 5
mais c'est avec la demande v6 ici je
sais pas
si sûr à 100 qu'il y apparaître comme
les bd calais b 5 derrière c'est pas la
question il a fait vraiment il a joué le
foot donc voilà il était dans cette
position il a joué à non non non il a
joué le foot est roi il a fauché trois
sets ce qui change en
3g 3 c c'est autre chose donc il veut il
propose tout de suite les changes des
fous ne pas prendre part je crois à mon
avis doit prendre effet bien un petit
peu la structure est bien sûr le roi
quand même se situe à l'air un petit peu
rapide pour les pour les internautes qui
ont du mal à suivre
suivre toutes ses variantes donc c'est
pour ça je vais tard été régulièrement
d'accord pour pouvoir expliquer avec des
mots peut être un peu plus simple je
pense qu'il faut échanger les fous et
le roi depuis en boucle et sont mal
placés quand même c'est pour le fait
pire la position du roi et maintenant on
peut essayer de jouer les coups mais
regardez ici on ne peut pas à mon avis
faire d'un v6 maintenant on ne peut pas
faire à mon avis d'un v6 parce qu'il ya
toujours faut prendre ces six
maintenant la torah tac le koleos est
donc il faut prendre deux cavaliers et
d'en prendre des cinq ici est-ce qu'il
ya la contrainte sociale assez duré
environ deux heures donc là donc tout ça
ça explique que sur fou j'ai 3 6
marie-eve projet 3h projet 3 et tentent
d'investir maintenant ça ne marche pas à
cause de faucon cesseront france voilà
donc au lieu d'un v6 il faut chercher
une autre solution faut chercher notre
solution c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs
que bas reliefs réfléchit maintenant
puisque tant qu'il n'a pas trouvé bien
il réfléchit alors il ya donc une
question là qui est assez intéressante
quels sont les compensations de
barrières pour son pur isolé
mais c'est une bonne question
normalement cet homme défaut de la
structure c'est un ace est en défaut
permanent et la compensation elle doit
être provisoire dynamique donc
normalement c'est peut être le joue
contre l'euro adverse
s'il va affaiblir le roi ici il peut
essayer et peut-être scellé dès du fou
j'ai 3 également évidemment il double
bien qu'espéré
dans le même temps mais les roms font
rage quand même un petit peu oui
l'absence du roi ces compacts ouais
c'était 500 pages c'est comme relation
donc ici kasparov essaie de protéger son
roi sachant que le tueur isolé donc ne
va pas s'envoler kasparov les atouts des
bleus on les connaît ils vont bloquer en
délire mais la pression à l'intérieur
et s'il n'y a pas de mystère
l'impressionnant inférieur donc tout
simplement le pur isolé et là il est pas
si faible que ça mais les blancs sans
dieu vous savez il y as pour les blancs
et les aplats cinéday même quelque part
il faut étudier après l' échange de faux
évidemment g36 il va le faire maintenant
elle affirmé au nom je crois qu'il a
fait mais il a fait je crois qu il a
fait
et on ne sait pas encore ce qu'il a joué
iachini variés fils a joué à 7-6
6-7 1-6 attaque le fou donc moins
évidemment surtout pensé s'ils sont les
dix ans production b vous savez si les a
aidés à les options peut-être ai-je et
les chauffe-eau eu de coup de foudre je
crois qu'il est revenu en e2 va
exactement alors que la pendule il reste
dix neuf minutes tabarja fait 17 à garry
kasparov tous les temps en temps il se
passe rien de particulier la pendule
donc une faut évidement et changer les
pièces j'ai ri gueur le coup car les f-5
ici par exemple tout de suite oui
l'idée c'est de reprendre avec la dame
mais pour contrôler la case des cadres
toujours d'haguenau gamme en caisse ou
et ici je prends prend il a les deux
pieds noirs contrôler cette can makers
oui je n'ose même des cinq des quatre
tours derrière
regardez qu'est ce que j'ai calculé
peut-être je me trompe mais au lieu
d'échanger des six pourraient venir
seulement voilà si les blanches
d'emprunt des cinq ici c'est un pion jeu
full range étroit
avec les noirs ici dans brandan il ya
fou prend f dont intermédiaire d'accord
j'ai récupère le pion je récupère tout
simplement gérer les airs la porte
d'accès égalité effectivement ça c'est
des ventes compliqué tout ça on va pas
peut-être pas embrouiller nos
internautes ici a été jouée tour vite
tour vite sur quoi comme les ongles
incarnés
avant de commencer à commenter cette
question il ya des questions qui est
déjà quelle est ta plus belle partie
sachant que les joueurs ont des bases de
données qui vont pouvoir la retrouver il
a regardé je pense qu'on te
veel heckhoff votre véhicule et les
corps palma de majorque à
81,9 canada meilleur 89 d'accord mais
j'ai gagné le prix du botteur on sait
que donne des cours à paris le week end
de temps en temps ou est ce qu'on peut
se renseigner si on est parisien et
qu'on a envie de fonder le sont avec toi
le plus simple
se prendre les contacts indirects soit
par e-mail
léopold of les rouler à offendorf aol
com d'accord alors léopold offs et ses
clients elle peut au bo belle bo rfd
were f arobas à welcome auo.com voilà il
n'y a pas de point d'attirer c'est
brutal
conserver le corps donc
ici c'est que relève décote c'était dans
nos pronostics pour toujours simplifier
la position il semblerait que de fou
soit sur le point de se faire échanger
les enfin les quatre fous de l'échiquier
sont tous en prison d'être doué mais il
faut le faire c'est pas si dramatique je
crois c'est toujours très très
légèrement mieux rien de spécial on peut
prendre tous les deux on ne prendrait
une ado et angers 3 fr dans b6
et d'un v6 à la fin
je crois que c'est lui après adorable et
deuxième tour quand les anges et six
titres dont cospar effet comme dans son
élément dans cette position il est très
à l'aise
il ya des bonnes chances de tenir ici la
partie serralongue cet événement peut
pas gagner une miniature dans une
situation pareille il n'y a pas de
tactique il faut ramasser les ados
essaient d'exploiter à la faiblesse de
nos structures donc la première le
premier objectif de bas reliefs qui est
comme de ne pas perdre en quinze coups
puisqu'on sait quel sport fait très bien
préparée elle était déjà acquis oui
maintenant on va voir la partie va être
longue il reste seize minutes à chaque
joueur donc ça se tient complètement à
la pendule un peu plus que 16 minutes 7
minutes 40 et donc tout devient possible
qu'il y avait quatre c'est le thermique
garry kasparov maintenant d'après iossif
dorfman les noirs peuvent échanger les
quatre fou fou prend fou prend fou on
échange tout et ensuite on a juste un
léger désavantage à cause du pur isolé
mais rien de bien particulier la partie
va être très longue être donc très
intéressante à une finale une finale
risque sûrement avec astana où il va il
va chercher une finale va peut-être
quelques pas avec la disparition du
qatar fou il peut envisager cavaliers de
4,36 oui quelque part comme idée et sur
besbre ans et six placées l'aide d'armes
en d4 et que volé 11,5 cherchait cette
disposition une sorte de plus faire ce
recadrage voilà ça c'est peut être son
idée quelque part c'est pour ça que j'ai
recommandé la bande des six déjà en
prévision de cet été d'accord donc ça
c'est ça c'est très très subtil ans
compte bien voir là bas et on ne s'est
pas donc c'est pas évident ce n'est pas
fait encore évidemment pour l'instant il
ya le problème du coût concret
a priori il ya aucune variante tactique
a calculé dans cette position on peut
calculer tout ce qu'on mange bio calculé
par exemple si vous partez avec faut
prendre g3 il faut étudier les
conséquences du faux branger canada
c'est simple si on trouve d'abord ce
foulard par exemple on peut y avoir des
échanges croisés mais pour éviter ça on
peut commencer par faut prendre en main
pour ne pas étudier on a envie de
changer tous les cadres de notre sens on
peut commencer par park faut prendre
espérons 21 il a pris en fous pareils
est effectivement il a joué exactement
je crois
bill de cif il voulait pas trop
s'ennuyer à calculer le prend d'abord en
deux gars et espère voir prendre de la
dame soit simplement il est là de la
tour où est ce normal ballons joués dam
des termes de 2,8 ou d'amd d'eau et
wahaha oui en tout cas ramené sa
deuxième tour sur la colonne dieu qui
est la seule colonne ouverte donc a
priori les toutes les tours vont
s'échanger aussi prochainement marié
fait je t'aime destatis
solide
oui pourquoi le jeu dame 17 parce que
les blancs sont obligé d'améliorer la
situation de leurs droits on ne peut pas
faire une f3 nuage 3 évidemment à cause
du four en fout donc il serait obligé de
prendre un des six lui-même garer et
après peut-être joué j'ai trois donc
paris avait laissé tout simplement
économiser un petit peu de temps pour le
pour le développement de ses pires il a
pris notamment des systèmes on assiste
effectivement comme tu dis aussi s'est
bien gardé espoir de printemps un
boucher son pion à faire une fenêtre
pour le roi en tout cas montrent des
gens que son roi où je sais pas qu'est
ce qu'il va choisir chez cacao au g3
soleil permanent au h3 où il peut
continuer le développement par dans des
deux est au aaa en général ils achètent
à nouveau un guéridon un
homme pression pas mal parce que l écho
et maintenant marié il serait obligé de
j'ai peut-être eu un effet paradoxal
maintenant pourquoi parce que c'est
moderne de 7 et les appart ou encore
cavalli ac 5 alors on peut regarder
enfin on va montrer sa cigarette est
aussi variable soudaine 17 pour défendre
la tour est vite malgré ce conte etc et
c5 c'est désagréable quand même un petit
peu de succès quand ça dure
donc ici il ya un problème en jeu penche
sur la période moi je pense qu'on aura
une suite normale pronostics ces trois
fuites ce coup là pour préparer coeur
léger 6 kg 6 et donc de toutes façons
les tours vont être échangés comme
ouverte tous les pièces échange de et
vous savez parfois il ya le compteur
joue avec la casse c4 c4 c4 locaux les
noirs puent le révérend ses cadres
surtout après que régis 6 415 et ses
cadres plus tard les bressans qui est un
petit peu démago
résister alors naba ya une question donc
intéressante effectivement est ce que
les changes des pièces lourdes avantage
garry kasparov
c'est une question pas pas forcément
facile ça nous vient d'une chaîne moi je
pense que non si on enlève ici les dames
et les quatre taureaux ne peut pas venir
cette pression et juan horrach montant
de 6,6 c'est une mule donc ça allège
simplement la défense devra y est moi je
mens je pense que que échanger les tours
et joué avec les dom et quatre cavaliers
c'est pas de faire la meilleure chance
pour garer ou échange mm quelque part en
cavalier avec les modifications de la
structure prendre quelque part peut-être
en c6 d'accord donc d'après toi prononcé
six et permettre des princes et 6 c'est
pas forcément une position donc la
position avec la dame on à s'ancrer
garder quelque part dans mon assiette
connaissez sens et c'est un pionnier
âgées après les changes dont il ya des
modifications structures possibles au
niveau des échanges de pièces il n'y a
rien de bien percutant mise à part que
non mais c'est difficile il faut bien de
prendre l'aventage blanc min il ya
presque rien
vous pouvez faire tout ce que voulait
après roi fit peut-être gars il va
essayer dans ces trois taureaux torrent
et c'est moi et je rêvais d'andré moi
c'était clair c'est prédit alors qu'est
la pendule il reste treize minutes à
bari a fait 16 actes esbroufe donc ckac
sports qui pour un peu les initiatives à
la pendule mais enfin tout ça ça ne
compte pas vraiment youssif ce qui est
important c'est comme les trois quatre
dernières minutes c'est la pluie
commence à regarder vraiment garder
cette position comment progresser avec
les blancs moi j'ai enlevé par exemple
faire cavalier français 6 si on joue ici
puis en train et scipion tronqué une
erreur à mon avis si on prend faire dans
ces trois oui je prépare ton a eu un on
va on va montrer c'est une supposition
qui est pensé si seulement il ajouté ces
trois gary catt noir le guen sur danger
3g je vous le dis oui pourquoi je sache
vous l'expliquer justement parce que ces
pays ont immédiatement il prend avec le
cavalier donc maintenant maintenant il
va faire presque sûrement tort s'est
vite je pense respect seront assez vite
puisque lie à la casse et 5
effectivement de garry kasparov est ce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il est assez
simple dans cette position avec 7 hors
série de sept ans passés les des oui
mais va co et on peut perdre la pièce il
maintient la pression autant oui joue
vite bien kasparov survie c'est plus
facile pour les airs savez il vise la
finale et peut faire dans cette romance
et au torse et vite c'est très probable
qu'il va faire dans j'ai trouvé pour
échanger les dents prendre à g et mais
je pense que ceux qui veulent
absolument j'ai déjà regardé comme d'un
f3 avec eux des choses en
6320 on est la deuxième tour oui mais
sur des restos à étudier comment les
cinq attaques la dame après qu'elle ait
eu cet objet 6 comme a laissé 4 c'est le
conteur choqué que je propose à
l'accordéon p3l couche là elle ne
participe pas donc la position est très
compliqué à mon avis c'est très proche
de ses livres ça commence à devenir
assez d'actifs qu'est ce qui est
recommandé pour kasparov surtout si vite
peut-être dam des trois qui vise dommage
cette araignée de temps si c'est oui et
après si on agite à nouveau tôt il n'y a
pas qu'à l'aller on sent qu'il est
cohérent un set ça ça c'est une idée que
ça s'ébruite donc c'est ça devient un
peu dangereux mais sur donne des
trophées il ya danger 6 il ya deux
justices nationales ici un objet si ça
marche parce que si finalement il ya
lancé marche tout est protégé votant
pour moi
sur dam des trois dames âgées s'en fait
aussi vite surtout oui c'est évident de
danger si
les problèmes particuliers donc varier
peut-être faire une bonne performance
alors je sais pas au début tu nous a dit
qu'il avait des mauvais résultats contre
garry kasparov et le jeu très mal ça
vient d'où oui nous avons de très bonnes
relations avec bar et on parle souvent
une mare compter avec leur entraîneur
est ce que c'est horrible pour lui la
tombe est dans le vent deux consécutives
contre caspar avec un succès toujours
preview perdre contre l'espagne mais
l'avait encore capable en deux mois et
les pertes d'eau partir amélie tu es
bien contre qu'espace de séjour mais je
me souviendrai bien voilà c'est une
estonienne grossistes en diamants
vraiment charlie munger et espère que
l'arnaqué oui mais mais ici ici c'est
plutôt la position arabe arrive parce
que je ne vois pas comment les blancs
peuvent percer la pression il faut faire
petit à petit
c'est pas très grave moi si je compte de
l'espérance est parti je suis content
oui mais ça veut dire qu'il a passé le
stade de l'ouverture les maps rôle de
regarder même ici si je cavale et e5 ici
sur d'objets trois quarts les deux c4
même ça c'est jouable mais tout s'est
vite je trouve que c'est peut-être garé
sur le tour c'est l'idée de le faire tôt
a tout simplement qu'avec ont cueilli un
peu les prendre car les épreuves qui
avait dit d'essayer fini barrière qui
prend l'initiative d'échangés il évitait
penser sinon on va évidemment qu'elle
devrait changer il va proposer le change
d'école et surtout aller prendre des 4l
va faire presque sûrement à mêler à
cavalaire sent que c'est comme laisser
si ce qu'est ce que la préparer là-bas
vous voyez qu'on va les prendre
maintenant il est tout à fait ses
preuves dans le groupe qui se veut jouer
voilà il sur le cavalier c6 sur 46 à mon
avis les accabler 500 qui a l'air de
gagner il faut faire danger si si si il
faut faire d'alger 6 donc s'attaquerait
en danger 6 est dans ce sens qu échec
ça se gagne 1.3 g8 et de confusion
il faut armer les changes ne gagne pas
vous voyez si vous faites un échange
intermédiaire tu reprends tôt le tour
contours d'abord et en titres
représentant les empreintes ça ne mange
pas parce que je croyais à 3,5 c'est
vrai cinq points c'est tout à fait ça
voilà c'est dit qu'elle veut gagner 3,5
ha au jeune et belle jeune homme alors
placé ici c'est une variante lamont trop
longue on va beaucoup trop vite non
puisque
c'est pas que ça peut arriver c'est que
il faut probablement expliquer des
choses un peu plus simple parce que
c'est vrai que là quand on enchaîne
disque ou de suite tout le monde ne peut
pas suivre qu'est ce qu'il ya sur
l'échiquier il réfléchit pas lui mettre
au grand mère carole et c6 et l'a fait
il a fait qu'on a laissé six donc c'est
à gré
à décider maintenant il a joué qu il
nécessite donc oui donc ça peut être
effectivement là-bas on en vient presque
c'est assez drôle donc et garry kasparov
peut jouer dans cette position le coup
cavalli et 5 qui est celui là qui a
l'air de conduire à une vente forcée au
classement en gagnant un pion est un
piège et voilà dans prince peut être
pareil drame secoue on verra c'est
possible c'est faisant le taux d'effort
c'est sûr qu'on relève simple menace
m'attendre je sais quoi il parle donc
d'un geste fort ses échecs bouche prise
prise prison gagnant oui mais à la fin
peut-être alors on va faire une petite
pause pour annoncer les pendules il
reste quatorze minutes à kasparov et 10
minutes a varié donc kasparov sont les
initiatives autant et on veut en
profiter donc pour vous remonterez la
ségrégation qui réfléchit on va vous
remonterez la variante c'est cavaliers
le cinq attaques la dame menace m'attend
g7 d'alger six dames c5 et chaque auront
manger vite et fort c'est maintenant
tourteron tour échec tour prend tout et
dames fonction des cinq gagnants pions
mais voilà on peut montrer la variante
jusqu'au bout 325 on prend à eux cinq
ils réussissent à gagner est sûre
qu'elle va les prend on a une fourchette
échec au roi qui récupère la dame j'ai
six majeur une proposition comme un
point noir à la place de devenir conteur
et sam cooper revenir si le plein toute
aventure sain et c'est aux rideaux ont
eu deux donc c'est un coup donc c'est
pour avoir des compensations en fait
dynamique oui ici il y as d'emprunt
cavalli amont il n'y a pas tord contrôle
voilà ici pour le pion il ya la
compensation après le roi en a 16 kg
lundi soir
je serai pas car même s'ils s'attaquent
le puits en f2 attaques benneteau a tant
que vous nous avez non non non ça c'est
drôle attaqué deux et attaques des deux
donc peut-être qu'il ya du jeu
effectivement mais il faut réunionnais
oui c'est évident sans l'attendre voilà
c'est comme ça pour l'instant et pour
les caps qui essaient six voeux par
mariette est là on attend le coup de
canon qui peut mettre le feu à
l'échiquier en jean qu'elle vive 5 et
vous savez je veux le dire que le tome
c'est combien maintenant alors il reste
neuf minutes 50 à barrière et 12 minutes
45 à garry kasparov oui je vous le dire
que dans l'impression de se joindre le
plus important c'est de des terminales s
est aussi si barry ville va avoir une
finale même un petit peu en fait rire
même est très clair très connu et de
accéléré leur mouvement et faire toute
une série de coûts du très très haut
niveau techniquement il joue il est plus
technique oui comme tous les grands
maîtres du haut niveau mais le problème
c'est pour déterminer le 706 par une
voix maintenir en avoir la pression
trois minutes de plus sur des cd donc
une situation déterminée ça veut dire
quelque chose de connu classique on
connaît bien déjà l'heure de la rose
c'est seulement la déchire il n'y a pas
de moment critique il n'y a pas de choix
vraiment très importante à faire c'est
selon les techniques du jour des
techniques de sélection pour les deux
fonctions que bf arrive à simplifier la
situation enfin la déterminer justement
pour pouvoir se référer ce qu'il connaît
déjà et si kasparov peut lui mettre la
pression en lui proposant des choix
complexe et bien ce moment là si dans
une note eh bien ça peut se retourner
contre lui irini brian may cette
variante que nous avons dit que j'étais
leur île et hop elle est très probable
oui elle est très très près les acteurs
de l'eau et votre profession comme les
trois etc etc
ça pu interviewer chicago quelques cours
donc on va atteindre on va voir ça
risque d'être très très intéressant s'il
va suivre donc on va peut-être mettre
des plans sur les joueurs histoire de
voir un peu la tête qu'ils font quand
même assez à ce stade de la partie à peu
près à la vie partie donc là on voit les
deux joueurs garry kasparov et kenny bas
relief
garry kasparov concentraient donc comme
tu dis bien si c'est un acteur donc de
toutes façons tout et c'est même plus de
savoir non sont en ce moment là je crois
qu'il est correct il n'y a pas de
grimaces nuances allait commencer
pendant le match à son compte
les cartes envoyées gréement se faisait
pas avant non non pas je me serais une
partie car pelé fait une gaffe terrible
et et caisses parole à mon traître de
monde dans la salle comment c'est pas
cher c'est quoi c'est comme dans un
jardin public
avant de prendre cette
tournée
c'est nouveau
et la portée de chaque modèle
est là donc barriac lui c'est le calme
absolu oh non il est très correct bref
toujours avec tout le monde très bien
très intelligent un joueur sympathique
on propose sur le château en vain c'est
un coût qui n'est pas nocif percutant
oui encore mal aussi mais regardez ici
au fait vous êtes prêt à échanger
la cata retour je peux changer les tours
et je vais à nouveau trop vite et je ne
vois pas déjà la matière est le seul
échec et pour gagner cette partie mais
c'est il ya pratiquement rien du tout
donc c'est à dire que après les échanges
générale de toutes les tours et bien il
reste plus beaucoup de matériel donc
plus beaucoup de chances de gain
si quelqu'un veut agir c'est plutôt
maintenant jean a priori l'hypothèse de
travail que je propose n'est pas très
bon parce que si on change tout les
tourteaux prendre prend et très vite
après les changes on peut vite on peut
même écrire de cette aura qui est pas
moi ne peut être commun
excuse moi aussi c'est une question qui
est intéressant voire en cas de finale
deux pions si on enlève toutes les
pièces est ce que les blancs une chance
de gain puisque je suppose que les
membres ça dépend si laurent blanc au t4
oui ça peut être très difficile à gagner
mais mairie a les possibilités mais
normalement c'est nul le final très
difficile à tenir
torrance était c'était peut-être une
bonne proposition de la preuve c'est que
kasparov a joué donc en tout cas c'était
une proposition vérité voilà ben serait
évidemment on ne peut pas échanger à 4
tours c'est bien que la chaîne ne
pourront montrer maintenant les
variantes si on ajouté au printemps oui
tu en prends et turvy temps nouveaux
évidemment qu'il prend on ne vide oui
répond-il maintenant au cavalière 50
lève le pied je sais qu'avec les chefs
sawa la question j'ai cet été mais même
ça c'est pas clair maintenant on va on
va terminer le bayern 4e 5e et d'armes
g6 quand même oui cavaler préemption est
roi et fuite les pompiers de lille et le
bien est pire gelé comme aller là bas
l'enfermement du calendrier ou alors
c'est encore une vente qu'on a montré
très vite on va regarder tout ça la
position pour l'instant est la suivante
bien quel point le tour avant il double
les tours sur la colonne a priori
n'avait de siphon ses célèbres parce que
tu as montré la variante ça a l'air
d'être à peu près égale pavée de mots
assez c'est le moi j'achète des vins du
monde par exemple à l'époque car pauvre
quand je sens un cochon elle va révéler
ici est la masse est facile de cette
élite
c'était aussi alors qu'en fait on nous
demande qu'est ce qui se passe en cas de
nul et bien stéphane si j'ai bien
compris tu a confirmé sans doute les
matchs de départage seront joué dix
minutes après il ya une petite pause
voire d'amour dans ce règlement g vix
j'ai vu que ce plu c'était prévu à 18h
mais pour avoir la présence du maire à
la baisse des prix ils ont a priori
avancer ces matchs de parties rapides
alors maintenant je sais pas ça posera
peut-être des problèmes avec les joueurs
mais ça donne très très fort oui mais
les taignonnes cette partie donc nous
aurons des matchs de départage a priori
et en bits est ce que j ai fini braille
à fait à la hauteur de son niveau de jeu
je sais pas j'ai vu au village et
l'image des partages de la russie compte
de rêve qu'elle qu'il faut à drainer les
excédents n'oblige beaucoup plus forte
qu'à que kasparov plus fort que gaspard
non mais c'est évident mais j'ai des
comptes à kasparov camp et elle a tout
du moins de 85 kg la voiture presque à
chaque fois aller au bac s bon sens ne
s'est pas perdu
car
c'est connu
cette fois
ci c'est curieux rhioui bien sûr j'aime
pas qu'avant enfin il ya les vrais
spécialistes doublej massawa kasparov
d'accord et donc barrière barrière qui
se dresse en surtemps c'est surtout les
nerf du bar et ne sont pas des forges
oui bah oui puisqu'on sait que en
systèmes élimination directe par
ailleurs joue très bien alors attention
il faut encore faut-il qu'il fasse nul
dans cette partie et les bosses avec
nous l'on peut faire pratiquement par
n'importe quel moyen que j'ai hâte de
reprendre tombe non je crois qu'il est
tout autre chose il a joué comme beckham
l'a mené
4-1 coup
donc est-ce qu'ils faussent les finales
est-ce qu'il force s'il force et final
c'est extraordinaire comme un jeu c'est
le plus simple s'il force les finales
donc de cavaliers c'est à dire si kia
sport sera obligé de par exemple prendre
b4 ensuite de prendre tout 1,8 et bien
ça c'est une finale de cavaliers qui
seraient dus le plaçant au grain
seront en on avait très bien placé pour
le final oui beaucoup mieux alors oui il
passe tout de suite non mais je crois
qu'elle est noire des risques à lyon
dans les finales c'est il faut faire
attention avec lui puisqu'il est
rarement très vite en dès 6 ans et 5 ans
nous sommes donc défendre ses droits la
professeure d'insurgés noter que c'est
la dame bougies un beau piège
tout à fait si la dame vient
venturi toute façon la dame peux pas
trop bouger non le fpi a changé deux
fois en me vis était donné un échec 1 1
à 3 mais ça donne rien il y à déjà d'un
mot 7 et même si roy bouge quelque part
alors atteint sur yousif ça va trop vite
jeudi ont pu échanger ou quatre tours
bien sûr oui quatre tours leroy reprend
il donnait chez quentin 3 mai mais ici
les noirs ne risque rien parce que
lorsque l'attaqué puis un bep de le
devenir des cadres le mensonge
alors que on a une proposition de
l'ordinateur iossif qui dit qu'après
d'apprendre 4 camani prompt et les
chants générale de toutes les tours les
plans c'est un petit peu mieux non non
parce que les créateurs et le juge la
pression sur la base de la structure oui
il ya les plus les priorités par devant
notaire est ici pour lui évidemment elle
est un pion désolé mais après les noirs
attaque le pion à dos si vous changez
tout il faut faire à trois cavaliers c6
est à mon avis il faut tout simplement
ces éléments il faut faire c'est 3
proposait n'y a rien que je sais pas
quelle est l'opinion d'ordinateur sur ce
sujet mais à mon avis c'est nul
pratiquement forcé sans doute en tout
cas donc c'est juste l'évaluation de
l'ordinateur qui donc a l'air basé sur
des mauvais principe vous savez qu est
ce qu elle a dit correctionnel récemment
il a dit que je n'allais jamais avec les
à l'inter parce qu'il donne un avantage
j'ai fait mon cou il donne la version
proposée médiatement c'est pour ça il
faut utiliser le mode
il y à l'option tactique ou d'
extrêmement fort de la terre peut-être
plus fort déjà que sparrow dans l'option
concret mais tandis que deux options
stratégiques il est encore relativement
faible il rejoint moins forts qu'eux en
rose tu as des biens beaucoup de choses
à faire des ponts grand maître donc ça
ça va nous sommes sauvés
l'ordinateur encore des progrès à faire
bilan pendule puisque ça devient chaud
il y aussi figuraient sept minutes à
chacun des deux joueurs donc tu l'as dit
si la pression à déterminer c'est pas
une question de temps les joueurs
peuvent jouer très vite on agrège on est
déjà allé détermine l est et elle a
terminé à mon avis une mule rapide c'est
mon pronostic nous leur nul dans
quelques poules alors que là on ne
propose cavaliers f5 qui a pas l'air
d'être un bon coup donc elle s'associe
maintenant voyez d'emprunt d'en prendre
apparemment kerviel 5 maintenant non
seulement à dire d'en prendre un enfant
et des structures de toronto n'était pas
prêt et après tu reprends toretto
d'éviter les noirs sont mis pour les
bêtes à cornes et des 6 et noir sont
très bien voilà donc la réponse qui veut
dire 5 n'est pas un bon coup non il faut
échanger les dames c'est évident on va
faire comme prendre un celi kasparov là
il fait effet quelques grimaces la
normale a raté son coup il n'a pas vu ce
coup donc il n'ya pas aucun avantage
vous disant que c'est désagréable quand
même avec le blanc et l'annulaire
facilement pareil ils facilement tout à
fait donc ce serait un bon show à mon
avis non mais j'en tire il vous a répété
au filet peut-être choix il doit
peut-être dû jouer des 4 au début ou c4
le premier court no magic cicas parole
va répéter encore la française de
l'image de départage et évidemment elle
va jouer comme contre poids puisque
là-bas c'est très serré cette partie du
programme qu'il a gagné avec les
noirmont semaine ailleurs ces questions
qui fâchent le code contre paul biya non
non non j'ai dit que ric o'barry en cas
de cavale et c3 oui contre la française
il va répéter peut-être la variante dire
qu'il a joué contre paul bert à une
équipe très solide qui est donc lui
aussi ses pions provost 4 avec voilà
comprend la terre de foot ou de suite
sur le stand urbain stage au camp nou il
me semble que c'est ça va tout alors des
dizaines d'habitants donc donc d'après
toi y'a siffla nul devrait être signée
de tomber rappelons quand même que c'est
des combattants ici c'est des fighters
et promet 4 et 3 f1 a été prof de jouer
pour un avantage minimum à noter qu'il a
donnée puis à 2 quand même bien et
kasparov oui c'est un piège non mais
c'est intéressant qu'est ce que la
prépresse et au ponton maintenant on l'a
par exemple tu en prends ton temps qu'en
retour il faut prendre le leader du tour
voile à prendre tôt et par les pompiers
oui pour arrêter le cavalier il faut
faire ces trois oui c'est maintenant
j'ai purgés enfin c'est roanne en
attaque lui aussi fils les isséens et
qui a été avalée c'est en effet le
couteau des douleurs
on va amoindrir le choc la variante dont
qui signe un sacrifice de varier peut
jouer pour contours des sports doit
prendre de la tour et que wade prend
pions et cahiers de fonction évidemment
je répète c'est pas nécessaire après que
blessé six étapes sont absolument égal
mais on imagine que les jeux comme ça
oui et donc maintenant c'est trop a
pratiquement obligé autrement il n'y a
rien oui maintenant on commence on
retire donc ici il faut étudier b5 avec
les db 4 et 5 ya une question aussi
nocifs comme on l'était plus qualifié de
roi
roy a eu un scélérat au oui mais
lecavalier ne sort pas mais il ya à
104,3 ici il ya même un noble et pato un
eto'o a à ça c'est assez rapide aux
oratoire qu'un local il ya donc voilà et
pour cette raison même dessein que c'est
pas évident regret db5 taurin par
exemple tôt un bagad taux à 1
et et en perdre le canadien mon père a
permis à vincent il y avait 3 suite
tournait vite peut-être avec des chances
de nul également c'est vrai oui
peut-être même scénario tort peut-être
oui mais roanne se déplace là s'il veut
faire du niveau mieux sans doute voilà à
revenir tout simplement une position
après avoir forcé la partie en cours ne
pas se poser de questions je vous êtes
aux contours et qu'elle et ses six
autour prendront le taureau vit proposer
les changements et du tout kasparov
presque seulement elle va refuser elle
va faire tour du doubs
devrait essayer le jeu contre le pion
m'isoler mais avec ou sans matériel
c'est impossible il ya plus un matériau
léger simple ordinateur propose qu avant
de s'étirer
c'est un peu loin moi vous savez
l'ordinateur parfois ils trouvent trois
pilotes pour la pièce dans notre vrai
que j'ai indiquées lors il l'a fait il
est fait des reprises de questions va
reprendre de la tour c'est quasiment sûr
nar autrement ils perdent un pied en
maintenant sa seront ils à targon me
perds mon temps puisqu'il ya toujours
huit échecs et qui avait du pain de à la
fin wade a pris la tournée je crois à
vérifier
il ya peu du roi alaouite au cif donc je
suis non elle n'est pas foutu vous savez
qu est ce qu elle a étudié pas d'être si
maintenant échec oui roi des dos
les deux tons prend tôt alors ça va être
encore une variante longue mais là les
ventes sont simples puisqu'elles sont
quasiment forcé enfin en tout cas très
critiques donc tour vite échec roi des
droits des deux taupes en tout temps
qu'en retour on prend toujours grise du
pays auxquels ces trois oui roi des dons
et lecavalier ne sera pas cette fois ci
au fait 3 c en 3d d'autres il va pas
sortir et c'est un il y aurait droit des
droits des temps qu'on peut pas prendre
dans le piège j'aime pas ça d'accord
donc à l'enseigné ça joue sajou ou sajoo
non mais les chefs ses collègues pour
faire nul c'est quand même une fois pas
prendre l'opinion tour échec 3d 2
toronto c'est normal on sent la
proposition de loi pour tour de kasparov
donc l'avarié réfléchi leurs bilans
portugal à 5 minutes à kasparov et 4
minutes 20 à bas reliefs d'y réfléchir à
ce qu'ils pensent pions ou est-ce qu'il
revient en c6 je peux vous dire qu'il y
a le seul risque dans cette position que
prend on peut perdre le final depuis un
an d'option après quelqu'un sait si ce
après que les princes il y a les
perspectives du pylône passé éloigné
c'est vraiment très sur l'échiquier
comment comme on arrive dans cette
situation quelque part après les charges
oui donc alors là on va vous montrer le
concède mais pas toutes ces questions ne
compte absolument après les chemins
différents sur quel quai par les blancs
réalise le plan avec ses cadres et ses
prendre des cinq ils jouent ces quatre
décès prend ce dessin et après et après
on va éloigner l'euro en noir oui avec
une diversion voilà et chercher le pays
en haleine durant tout à fait en finale
d'options sélection peut s'éloigner qui
fait la différence point sur la position
c'est celle là bas relief n'a pas encore
joué ces six mais d'après iossif dorfman
et bien sûr qu'ils essaient si ce qui
est processus pur procès si c'est
peut-être des chances mais sur ces
cadeaux suffit de prendre ses quatre
roues en vente
euros avec déjà en d6 donc oui mais
c'est un petit et d'options et les
possibilités offertes sont tout
simplement jouissif il peut même le roi
marois d2 jusqu'au 1/5 non mais bien sûr
cela me fait rire c'est moi je pense
il va faire froid des douilles
maintenant je pensais que j'ai 6 et le
coup mon avis j'ai six s'étaient
présentés lorient voilà et c'est une
bonne chose pour le roi mais la question
je suis fils a joué des citations roy
s'est rangé si j'ai l'impression que ça
fait tout de suite après moi c'est toi
ça peut pas perdre officielle jana
heureusement voilà non mais levage
vergès et 3 d'abord à 3 3 comme les 6 et
après pour jouer pour gagner il faut
absolument faire comme les prendre six
autres - une énergie complètement celle
ci nul semble donc là c'est très chaud
il reste trois minutes variés quatre
militants aguerris castorf on voit tout
le temps c'est une constante chez gary
kasparov que dès qu'ils commencent à
voir plus beaucoup de temps à la pendule
et bien c'est lui qui est mieux
c'est pas de commentaire ouais pas
d'être un simple constat tout simplement
effectivement le constater alors le coût
attendu je prends moi je pense que c'est
à 2 à 3 mutine et à moi mal ordinateurs
proposent f4 n'importe quoi bon or donc
le coup c'est probablement à 2 à 3 c'est
vrai que la tête d' ailleurs siph quand
on les propose à ce qu'a très bien cette
vous ça ne vous encourage pas écouté
l'ordinateur
alors chez sis dont qu'est ce que c'est
possible qu'elle ne soit signé dans les
secondes qui viennent
pas encore peut-être aller encore un peu
mais pas beaucoup mais il est encore les
chiens regardez par exemple j'ai donné
que à 3,7 revient on peut pas
malheureusement parce que si les arbres
à ces trois
s'échoue il faut j'ai chaos nécessite
donc ce que l'accord allait prendre
comme les héros avec à 3,5 oui tout à
fait là bas des normes peut-être espérer
de gagner ni même vous voyez d'autres
possibilités aussi pour des cas tb4 par
exemple
rémy est également bien ce n'était pas
mal non plus qu'on nous dit attendez
mais c'est vrai qu'on attende ya des
problèmes dans cette pièce de pions donc
on rappelle que les joueurs jouent pour
le titre de champion du monde
simplement de parties rapides donc c'est
important garry kasparov
bon bien kasparov ya aussi fait juste un
mot d'après toi ses meilleurs joueurs du
monde actuellement une chronique à
nantes peuvent éventuellement non mais
ici au tall toujours enfants le titre de
champion du monde et les numéros un
mondiales pourquoi dans les autres
disciplines c'est absolument clair et
les numéros un mondiales et la
championne du monde de cette année en
tennis il n'y a pas de discussion agassi
aujourd'hui ce numéro mondial mais la
chaîne de prêt à porter qui paraît
aujourd'hui c'est donc aujourd'hui c'est
secret mais qu'elle n'est pas le
champion du monde et le gagner le match
à 3 6 et 6 qui a dépensé 6 kg on prend
et c4 de garry kasparov ça va très vite
là et ça chauffe trois des six on est
évidemment maintenant aussi puis on
prend on va prendre des 5 et 6 et 6,5 et
seniors donc en droit des trois normales
as tu l'avais dit le plan avec ses 4
maintenant il faut faire à mon avis roy
5 je crois en eux 5
pourquoi pas je ne sais pas finale
d'options donc pronostics nul quand même
à briller mais il faut faire les coûts
précis avec comme il faut jouer avec les
noirs alors une petite question juste
jouissif sur le chat dans ce grand
moment est ce que tu peux redevenir
aujourd'hui par exemple entraîneur de
kasparov
je crois pas après
c'est pas vrai si on avait kasparov qui
décident parce que les relations restent
absolument normal c'est autre chose
après l'expérience que j'ai eue que
dernière tombe peut-être je vais inviter
du cobaric joueurs de très haut niveau
parce que ça n'apporte aux quelque chose
au niveau de morale 1 donc moi je
préfère donner les cours tout simplement
tranquille tranquille d'azur mon partout
mais pour né pas m'engager de vaud
comprennent encore attendre quelque
chose au niveau moral on ne peut pas
attendre la mairie à calais moi
j'attends toujours ça faisait un grand
fou
d'accord alors il reste 2030 à kasparov
deux minutes à yevgeny marif la finale
d'options à l'air égale à 5 b3 et les
deux derniers coups joués donc la docile
toi tu invites tout le temps en finale
aux cures à monter la sauce avec un peu
peur dans cette position avec le nord je
peux donner confiance à qui a été joué
voilà c'est normal car il va prendre
rendez 5 c'est évidemment roi prend
airois c3 il faut faire c'est 6 et 5 il
n'a pas joué il a joué ses trois
galeries ça y est c'est fait il faut
faire absolument c5 à mon avis la menace
cb4 et de fond avec la menace si vous
fêtera ses 5 3 540 terrible à 4 et b4
plus tard et nelly tard oui tout à fait
mais le viol vous comprendre les
français semblent ses techniques ses
techniques ce moment c'est à dire qu'une
fois absolument éviter des changes des
pions a et b sinon c'est l'option pas
s'éloigner moi même et sur ses 5 îles et
à l'aider à 3 à 4 il a joué h5 qu'est ce
que c'est que ça assure maintenant
mirallas normal celui katia 4 et la
direction fait jouer h4 barriac fait f6
ça joue très vite deux minutes 13 pour
kasparov une minute 20 pour barrières et
ils sont 35 et le coup elle noté qu 50e
on leur ajoute discompte parcours donc
une position d'un petit peu désagréable
pour paris offre quand même oui
attention là il peut jouer vite g5 et en
cas de g3 qu il al air forcé g3 est
forcément ma car il va faire et au roi
ou quatre noms mais il n'est donc pas
certain qu'il prépare oui j'ai cinq
maintenant
est normal g5 gsm sur le coup normal je
ne sais pas j'ai s'inquiéter jouer et
oui tout à fait
j'ai 5 mais c'est important on peut
rêver t elle écoute attentive aussi au
fait j'ai trois je préfère g5 g4 et
japonais ont la charge et 3 ont fait g4
et on se laisse un petit coup de réserve
pour gagner du temps le golf 5 g iii
joué par kasparov tu reproches 4 a
priori qu'à soir de répondre c'est fait
f5 de barrières bon là c'est très chaud
cette position l'ordinateur annonce
petit avantage non mais les sief 4
maintenant à f4 et les jo c'est cinq
mois la trève quatre accès sans que tu
en as position c'est ça l'idée pariez
pas vraiment des f4 c5 c6 à 4 pour les
blancs oui à 4 probablement il faut
faire trois des six résisteront à ses 86
donc ça sera des cases conjuguer
puisqu'on est voisin gestion y aura-t-il
des caisses conjugués et bien oui oui on
sait c'est ici après il peut y en avoir
ici après f4 de kasparov si le joug mais
je ne sais pas ce qu'il a joué il a joué
f3
f3 c'est justement pour inverser la
tendance peut-être
oui mais c'est aussi un jeu f 104 4
maintenant avec la new york est ce que
j'ai bien fait ce cadre c'est dangereux
il ya peut-être des 4 mois hugo cie fin
il semblerait que le roi blanc se mettre
à contourner les pions
on lui c'est vrai c'est vrai eh oui
roussin qui a été jouée
rôle 3 de kasparov il va forcer le 94
non il y as et cinq en ce moment là
c'est simple je veux pas mal ses sacs
ses 104 4 échecs cette fois puisque
quatre chèques et rodez 3 voilà il est
blanc et le blanc gagne du temps f 4
échecs on ça devient un joueur wade si
je crois pas ça fait mal
trois des six cd casse conjugué ses très
grands une via le pion à ce niveau de
jeu en d2 rocé 6 on ne comprend plus
roy c3 une minute à kasparov et 20
secondes restantes pour barrière mayroy
b55 rabais 5 5 et la qatar aux abysses
nulle roi le fait on va faire cinq
scènes où la cata droit b 6 nuls il a
fermé cinq mariages kasparov qui bouge
sur sa chaise il arrête pas de chez moi
des trois c'est le sol cos mais roy
détroit obligé si ça fait sale coup et
maintenant comment faire nul et la prime
cospar off i do ou à lampard f a
abandonné je ne sais pas je pense que
barace a dû abandonner on ne peut pas
savoir ce qui s'est passé normalement
ses bars et ses 6 et le perdre
maintenant sur abc sur la c4 ils perdent
également comment faire une eu la cote
après 0,1 l appel du mal je crois en
elle et l'a perdu il faut absolument
qu'on connaisse le résultat de cette
part je sais presque sûr qu'elle est un
héros il ya évidemment aussi il n'est
pas perdu il n'analyse pas la partie
évidemment qu'elle a perdu voilà voilà
et là des applications garry kasparov
donc est champion du monde deux parties
rapides et bien dit aussi fonds va te
libérer en tout cas merci beaucoup de
nous avoir comme évidemment et l'art
atteignent facilement avec ça c'est
évident oui tout à fait et bas reliefs
n'a pas réussi à tenir et donc dans se
donnent rendez vous tout à l'heure dans
au bar associatif
alors que nous restons en ligne avec
stéphane laborde pour cette remise de
prix c'est incroyable ce qui s'est passé
la finale on n'a pas compris finale
l'option garry kasparov fu fu yu il est
vraiment phénoménal ce gars hit & sport
il a gagné il lève le poing ils lèvent
le poing garry kasparov on veut lui
faire signer un autographe mais il n'en
est pas question il n'en est pas
question il est quand même cédé comme
méchant même page il a gagné il est très
méchant alors que nous allons rester en
ligne en attendant la serrurerie clôture
ce n'est pas parce que je crois qu'elle
a lieu tout de suite bientôt voilà nous
voyons bernard oheix qui arrive avec un
micro et qui va parler d'eux dans on va
vous les laissez pas tout de suite
encore dès qu'ils auront commencé à
parler
eh bien
eh bien ils parleront
en tout cas superbe super bien et
stéphane quand même un petit commentaire
le grand moment est arrivé
et en tout premier lieu je vais là
passer la parole à celui qui a permis la
réalisation de cette manifestation en
apportant une contribution financière
importante
c'est une nouvelle banque c'est une
équipe dynamique et jeune je présente
monsieur renaud sacy directeur général
de the bank partenaire officiel de la
coupe du monde
bonsoir à tous d'abord pour vous dire
que bien que représentants de banques je
suis aussi un enfant du pays un enfant
de cannes et que je suis ravi de revenir
dans cette journée qui a été fantastique
de jeu de sport d'émulation de
dépassement de soi et surtout
d'exécution rapide
ce sont des choses importantes pour nous
the banks est la première banque créée
au 21e siècle et c'est plus qu'une
banque c'est un véritable hypermarchés
bancaire on offre des prix du choix de
la commodité c'est la banque de chez
vous et il n'ya pas d'égal aujourd'hui
sur le marché on a tenu vraiment à
s'associer à la fédération française des
échecs pour un partenariat long terme
parce que ce bang c'est une équipe de
passionnés et on cherche à être présents
dans des communautés passionnées the
bank et proche des gens qui ont des
passions des gens qui veulent se
dépasser qui veulent aller plus loin
c'est toute notre philosophie voilà et
puis je remercie pleinement la
fédération des échecs l'organisation du
palais des festivals et enfin nos nos
brillants et valeureux joueurs qui nous
ont donné une belle après midi merci à
tous
bien la fédération française qui a
organisé ce festival cette coupe du
monde d'échecs rapide jean-claude
loubatière quelques mots jean claude sur
cette finale extraordinaire
oui mais écoutez c'est un grand moment
on avait voulu créer cette épreuve pour
plusieurs raisons l'une s'est créé une
compétition adaptée au troisième
millénaire c'est à dire une compétition
dynamique
et une compétition qui soit capable
nature et d'attirer un public très
nombreux
d'abord par internet et il ya eu des
centaines de milliers d'internautes qui
ont suivi par pendant quatre jours ce
tournoi
et puis aussi un public sur place et
donc vous là vous avez répondu présent
et vous avez montré que donc ces
compétitions elles doivent exister
puis aussi il faut dire que notre
fédération voulait
créer une coupe du monde mais une vraie
coupe du monde est une vraie coupe du
monde
c'est une coupe du monde où
les forges joueurs sont là et
une coupe du monde sans le numéro un
mondial s'est pas tout à fait une coupe
du monde alors nous avons essayé de
réussir ce pari
qui paraissait fou c'est à dire faire
venir garry kasparov
vous connaissez les problèmes qui
existent dans le monde des échecs vous
savez que garry kasparov n'a joué aucune
compétition de la fédération
internationale depuis individuelle
plutôt depuis dix ans et bien un gary
kasparov a accepté de venir ici à cannes
en france je crois que nous en sommes
très fiers au niveau de la fédération
parce que nous savons que s'il est venu
ici c'est une marque de confiance
vis-à-vis de notre fédération
voilà donc
l'événement a été superbe nous avons eu
la la cmec et la ville de cannes qui ont
été des partenaires extraordinaire et
les joueurs ont été exemplaires toute la
semaine et vous public vous étiez là
alors merci à tous
bon je vais appeler maintenant le grand
vainqueur de cette coupe du monde donc
celui qui je le disais tout à l'heure et
le numéro un mondial depuis 15 ans et
puis on dirait que c'est le même celui
qui est sorti un jour de l'ancienne
union soviétique
il est sorti comme
[Musique]
un taureau qui arrive dans l'arène et
vous savez que quand vous le voyez
arriver mais vous vous dites attention a
ajouté m vous dire juste une petite
anecdote pour aussi tué garry kasparov
parce que dès que je suis arrivé ici je
les appelais et je lui ai dit bon gars
et on mange ensemble on dit oui ok dans
un quart d'heure rendez vous que je lui
dis alors qu'anne commencer mdi commencé
quand il me dit on verra dans cinq jours
maintenant je peux vous dire cannes
c'est très très beau bien et avant
d'appeler donc garry kasparov et bien
quelqu'un qui compte pour la ville
quelqu'un sans qui ce festival n'aurait
pas lieu en tout cas qui va le porter
maintenant avec beaucoup d'énergie et de
passion votre nouveau maire monsieur
bernard brochand c'est sa première
sortie officielle je vous demande
vraiment de l'applaudir il est avec nous
il est dans le monde des jeux merci
merci beaucoup et comme toujours on sait
que cannes on vient nous le dira et
merveilleux cannes est une ville
extraordinaire cannes et la vie du
festival
des festivals il lui manquait si vous
voulez ce championnat du monde je crois
que la ville a prouvé aujourd'hui et
tous les organisateurs que on était prêt
à les accueillir très souvent et la
seule chose que je souhaite c'est qu'il
revienne à nouveau monsieur le président
la fédération
ici avec un public extraordinaire avec
bien entendu des jeux formidables et
avec des stars et des joueurs du talent
de kasparov en tout cas merci beaucoup
je pense qu'il faut tous et remercié et
les applaudir très fortement car nous
avons assisté à un spectacle à fait
extraordinaire et nous en redemandons
pour cannes et pour le monde entier
merci beaucoup
donc au nom de la fédération
internationale des échecs au nom de la
fédération française au nom de la
fédération de la ville de cannes dogues
monsieur brochand va remettre la coupe
trophée ce banques à monsieur garry
kasparov et je vous demande de lui faire
une ovation
[Applaudissements]
abo
c'est un grand moment pour moi devant
tout ce public et de donner tout seul
cette satisfaction c'est tous ceux
présents
à mon
niveau je
suis toujours heureux de voir tant du
temps du monde c'était un élément un
chacun
et c'est aussi
un plaisir un des chaînons que j'ai pas
du tout des gens qui sont venus me
soutenir
et je vais aussi tout ce qui à en
organiser cet événement de fédération
française des échecs et aussi des
mairies de cannes et toute personne ici
qui sont tm très bonne travail
d'organisation
[Applaudissements]
visitez can 98 101 ça me tenait
en 88 et septième ronde succès
et maintenant plusieurs années après
c'est encore un grand succès
donc je t'en prie
donc encore de visiter cannes dans les
prochaines années
[Applaudissements]
ce combat
et nous allons aussi applaudir le bal
euros finalistes d'evgeny barré yeves
evgeny barillet
second
de la coupe du monde trophée ce bang
merci de l'applaudir de lui faire
également une ovation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]